HI EVERYONE HELLO EVERYONE
AS WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE
TO THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT HEARING
WE'RE STARTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE TODAY WE HAVE A LOT
OF PROCEDURAL STUFF TO WORK
THROUGH HERE AND HOPEFULLY
-- MY COLLEAGUES -- WHO ARE
ON THIS DIESS WILL BE JOINING
US SHORTLY I KNOW WE HAVE
SOME MEMBERS HERE HER READY
TO TESTIFY SO LET'S LET'S
TRY TO GET THIS THING GOING
AT THE START I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE STAFF THAT HAVE MADE
OUR RETURN TO THE CAPITOL --
POSSIBLE TO HEAR BILLS DUE
TO ON GOING TO THE NINETEEN
SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE UNLIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN PERSON WE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE
WORN PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITES IF YOU NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU IT IS CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE OF THE HOUSE THAT
MEMBERS BE PROPERLY ATTIRED
FOR HEARING WEARING A MASK IS
ALSO A REQUIREMENT OF BEING
PROPERLY ATTIRED WE WILL HAVE
EIGHT BILLS ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY WE'RE ASKING AUTHORS TO
GIVE SYSTEM SUGGESTING SYSTEM
TWO PRESENTATIONS EACH BILL
CONNECT TO ME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION EACH
MAIN WITNESS GETS TWO MINUTES
EACH PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT
FOR ALL OTHER WITNESSES CALLING
IN TO REGISTER OR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON BILLS WE ASK
THAT YOU ONLY SAY YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU ARE WITH
AN ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL IF YOU SAY MORE
THE OPERATOR WILL CUT YOU
OFF IF YOU ARE UNABLE TO GET
THROUGH ON THE PHONE PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE PORTAL
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
THIS WILL BECOME PART OF THE
OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE BILL
YOU CAN ALSO SUBMIT AN EMAIL
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF WITH
A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF MEMBERS AT A LIMITED NUMBER
MEMBERS AND MINIMAL CONTINGENT
OF STAFF AND ELEVEN LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET
OF SPACING THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
HERE TODAY IN HEARING IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR LEAVE
YOUR SEATS PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USE TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE ROOM
AT WITNESSES IN THE PUBLIC CAN
MAKE USE OF ONE OF OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS LOCATED ON
THE NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY
FROM AT LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM AND ALSO I
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL THE CALL NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO
SIX AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SIX YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN
IF YOU ARE IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES READING
OR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY
FOR OR AGAINST A BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE ONLY
TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO EIGHT FIVE AGAIN YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT FIVE AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP YOU I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH --
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WE MAY NEED TO LIMIT
HOW LONG PHONE LINES ARE OPEN
FOR EACH BILL AS WE ARE ON A
TIGHT SCHEDULE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING
AND WE DO NOT HAVE OUR FIRST
FILE ITEM OF AUTHOR AVAILABLE
YEAH WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND
GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AND
THAT IS -- EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING AND CONGRATULATIONS
AGAIN ON BECOMING THE CHAIR
OF THE SIX DREAMLAND PORTENT
COMMITTEE -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASE TO THIS
MORNING TWO PERCENT EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY TWO A MEASURE THAT
WILL INCENTIVIZE CO HOUSING
APARTMENTS CO HOUSING ALSO
KNOWN AS COMMUNAL LIVING IS
TYPICALLY MADE UP OF UNITS THAT
ARE SMALLER THAN FOUR HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET BUT THAT OFFER
A SHARED KITCHEN AND DINING
AREA THESE ARE TYPICALLY MORE
AFFORDABLE THAN THE AVERAGE
STUDIO OR ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE THE AVERAGE RENT IS
ALSO WELL OVER THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO -- DEVELOPMENT
STAR CITY DEVELOPMENT COMPANY
STAR CITY BUILT CO HOUSING
UNITS THAT AVERAGE TWO HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET AND RENTED THEM
FOR FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH WHICH IS LESS THAN HALF
OF THE CITY'S AVERAGE ROUTE
THESE NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE UNITS ARE IDEAL
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T QUALIFY
FOR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING BUT
CAN'T COMPETE FOR MARKET RATE
APARTMENTS WHAT WE ARE GONNA
FREQUENTLY CALLED -- MISSING
METAL THE CO HOUSING MODEL
CAN ALSO BE USED TO HOUSE
SENIORS AND FORMERLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS SINCE COMMUNAL
LIVING PROVIDE A UNIQUE MIX
OF BOTH PRIVACY AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT UNFORTUNATELY LOCAL
RESTRICTIONS THAT REQUIRE A
MINIMUM UNIT SIZE OR A MAXIMUM
DENSITY HAVE MADE IT DIFFICULT
TO BUILD CO HOUSING APARTMENTS
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY TWO WILL
ALLOW CO HOUSING PROJECTS
TO QUALIFY FOR INCENTIVES
UNDER THE DENSITY BONUS LAW
AND HELP MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER
OF UNITS WITHIN AN ALREADY
COSTLY PARCEL OF LAND THE
MEASURE WILL REQUIRE DEED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE UNITS IN
EXCHANGE FOR CONCESSIONS AND
INCENTIVES SUCH AS INCREASED
DENSITY AND REDUCED PARKING
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY TWO WILL
HELP DIVERSIFY THE HOUSING
STOCK OFFERING BOTH NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND THE OPTION FOR COMMUNAL
LIVING TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS JANE BLUMENFELD
SENIOR FELLOW AT UCLA'S CITYLAB
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM
AND -- OPERATOR ANDERSON WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS AND SUPPORTS
-- AS MR -- MY COLLEAGUES
REMEMBER BLOOM HAS MENTIONED
AT JANE BLUMENFELD OF CITY
LAB IF YOU COULD OPEN THE
LINE FOR HER AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE NO NO IN OPPOSITION TO A
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
THAT BUT LET'S START WITH
THAT THE FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MY
LAST MY BEING HURT YEAH WE
CAN HEAR YOU OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JANE
BLUMENFELD AND I'M ASKING
YOUR FELLOW AT THE LEFT UCLA
HE LEADS UCLA IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB SIXTY TWO AND WE
THANK THE ASSEMBLY BUT FOR HIS
EFFORTS ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
CALIFORNIANS WELL DOCUMENTED
HOUSING CRISIS REQUIRES MANY
SOLUTIONS THERE IS NOT A
SINGLE FIX WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
STATE NEEDS POLLUTION'S BETTER
EFFECTIVE WITHOUT THE NEED
FOR PUBLIC DOLLARS WE NEED A
VARIETY OF HOUSING TYPOLOGIES
THAT CAN HELP PEOPLE HORRIBLY
ANDY PROFITABLE ENOUGH SO
THAT PEOPLE IN THE BUSINESS OF
BUILDING HOUSING WILL ACTUALLY
BUILD IT AB SIXTY TO CREATE
A NEW HELPING TYPOLOGY AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS DISCUSSED
AND THAT THIS HAS NOT BEEN
LEGAL FOR MANY REASONS OWNING
AND OTHERWISE IT MOST DIVERSITY
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY TWO WILL
ALLOW DEVELOPERS TO BUILD CO
HOUSING APARTMENT BUILDINGS
THAT COMPLY WITH LOCAL HI
GLORIA SETBACK REQUIREMENTS
BUT ALSO GIVE DEVELOPERS
THE ABILITY TO BUILD SMALLER
UNITS THAT INCLUDE A BATHROOM
SINK REFRIGERATOR MICROWAVE
KITCHENS AND DINING SPACES
WILL BE SHARED AMONG THE REST
CO HELPING BUILDINGS CAN BE
LOW RISE ARE HIGH RISE WHICH
SPEAKS TO THE FLEXIBILITY OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO WITH PARTICULARLY
APPROPRIATE FOR SENIORS
BECAUSE JOBS ARE ACTUALLY
A HAZARD FOR ELDERLY PEOPLE
I COMMUNITY DINING FILLS AN
IMPORTANT SOCIAL NEEDS AND
THERE'S VIRTUALLY NO HOUSING
AS IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED THAT
IT EVEN REMOTELY AFFORDABLE
CONVENIENT OTHER THAN INCOME
RESTRICTED HELP IN THIS TYPE
OF CO HELPING ALSO BE ATTRACTED
TO STUDENTS AND YOUNG PEOPLE
MILLION THE JOB MARKET WE'RE
WILLING TO SHARE KITCHEN IN
EXCHANGE FOR LEFT RENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM MENTIONED THE SAN
FRANCISCO START THE PROJECT
THAT BUILT ALMOST EXACTLY
TO THE SPECIFICATIONS OF
AB SIXTY TWO SIX EIGHTY TWO
SURE LIKE TO ADD THAT WHEN
IT FIRST OPENED THE BUILDING
WE STOP IMMEDIATELY AND HAD A
WAITING LIST OF EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
POPULATION REQUIRES HOUSING
UNIT THAT CAN BE DIFFERENT
NEEDS FOR SENIORS YOUNG PEOPLE
STUDENTS -- HOUSING OFFERS
THE RIGHT BALANCE THE PRIVACY
AFFORDABILITY AND COMMUNITY
LIKE RESPECTFULLY URGE I
THOUGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE NO
-- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE TO ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE
TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LAYS IN
GERMAN FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF A SPECIFIC BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO
BUT WE HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE
WHO SIGNALED THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLEASE
AND JUST A REMINDER PLEASE ONLY
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IF YOU'RE WITH AN ORGANIZATION
AND THEN SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
WE WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE SEVENTY JUST A
MOMENT ONE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI THERE MY NAME IS RYAN
JOY CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE INTO COURT
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
BY TWENTY FIVE
DAVID WHEATLEY A LOS
ANGELES CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
LINE SEVENTY FOUR
ONE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN YEAH THAT'S THE PART
I'M GOING TO GO ON TO
ONLINE SEVENTY SIX ELSEWHERE
STEVEN -- AS FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA IN FAVOR
GOING TO GO TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT HELLO ONE IS
OPEN JAMES DANIELS THE
HELLO YES SIR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ARE YOU A SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION I SUPPORT THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTERS IN Q.
WELL THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
BRING IT BACK UNDER THE
COMMITTEE HERE TO SEE IF ANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM ABOUT
HIS BILL EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO -- I I JUST WANNA THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW THAT -- SOMEONE
MEMBER BLOOM HAS BEEN ON
THE FOREFRONT OF LOOKING FOR
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS NOW AND HOUSING -- AND
THIS IS ONE OF THEM YOU KNOW AS
WE START TO LOOK AT PROPERTIES
IN THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO LOOK
AT HOUSING IN THE FUTURE WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT NEED TO LOOK
AT THESE TYPE OF SOLUTIONS AND
JUST LAST LASTLY ADD THAT I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY LIKE MANY OF
US TO TRAVEL ACROSS THE STATE
-- FOR HOUSING TOURS AND AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS WARD'S
WASN'T EXACTLY THIS BUT I'M
THINKING OF THAT ONE SMALL
DEVELOPMENT -- YOU CAN REMIND
ME THE NAME IF YOU SPEAK ON
IT BUT -- VERY CREATIVE IN THE
SIZE OF THE UNIT AND THE AND --
I THINK OFFERING SOME SOLUTIONS
NOT ONLY TO SENIORS BUT EVEN
TO STUDENTS SO I SUPPORT THIS
WILL MAKE A MOTION WITH OUR
SECOND ARE WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM
YET -- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS -- WHEN WE GET QUORUM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROWN WE WILL
WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND AND
WE WILL RETURN YOUR BILL THEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND DID
YOU WANNA CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS BILL HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO CREATE A SORT
OF MICRO EXPLOSION OF HOUSING
MUCH IN THE WAY THE REFORMS
TO EIGHTY YOU LAWS DEAD AND
TO SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVALS APPRECIATED AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY --
THINK IT'S AGAIN A CREATIVE --
WAY WE CAN TACKLE OUR HOUSING
CRISIS SO REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS ANIMAL BUT
I WE GET QUORUM THANK YOU
AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB EIGHT FIFTY FOR A
BI ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
SURE OKAY YEAH
GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS
D.
N.
YEAH YOU'RE WITNESSING COME
UP HERE -- THEY PREFER OKAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LINK
YOU MAY BEGIN THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING GREG CONGRATULATIONS
AGAIN AND I'M SURE GOOD TO SEE
YOU AT THE HELM OF THE SUPPORT
COMMITTEE FIRST I'D ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DUE DILIGENCE ON
THIS I'M SORRY ACTUALLY CAN
WE JUST PAUSE REALLY QUICKLY
WANT TO GET QUORUM -- SINCE
WE HAVE SOME COLLEGES JOIN US
WICKS HERE WICKS HERE SAY
ARE JUST HERE HERE AND HERE
CORREO GLORIA HERE GABRIEL
REVEALED KALRA KILEY MERCK
SILVA THANKS SILVA HERE WARD
WORTH HERE WE HAVE A CURRENT
GREAT THANK YOU SIR YOU MAY
BEGIN THANK YOU WELL FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER THE DUE DILIGENCE ON
THIS BILL AND I GLADLY ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
LIMIT THIS BILL TO RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS ONLY AND ALSO
AT THAT AS A CO AUTHOR SENATOR
BEN ALLEN -- THIS BILL SEEKS
TO PREVENT SPECULATIVE FICTIONS
BY REQUIRING A FIVE YEARS OF
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP BEFORE THE
ONSET CAN BE INVOKED THE ONSET
NOW WAS ORIGINALLY PASSED TO
ALLOW MOM AND POP LANDLORDS
TO LEAVE THE RENTAL HOUSING
BUSINESS WITHOUT SELLING THEIR
PROPERTY HOWEVER THE ELLIS
ACT HAS BEEN ABUSED BY POPULAR
PROPERTY SPECULATORS WHO REMOVE
UNITS MARKED FOR THE HOUSING
SUPPLY FOR PROFIT STUDIES SHOW
THAT SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF RECENT ELLIS ACT EVICTIONS
OCCUR WITHIN THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF A HONOR PURCHASING
THE PROPERTY AND ONE IN
THREE UNITS ARE L.
SPY KNOWN SERIAL OF VICTOR'S
MEANING THAT THEY HAVE ENTERED
EXITED REINSERT HENRY EXITED
THE RENTAL BUSINESS MULTIPLE
TIMES AND EVICTING TENANTS FROM
MULTIPLE BUILDINGS BY CREATING
A FIVE YEAR HOLDING PERIOD
BEFORE THE ON SECOND INVOKED
ARBIL CONTINUES TO RESPECT
LONG TERM LANDLORDS ESPECIALLY
THE SMALLER SCALE LANDLORDS
WE HAVE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS
FOR DECADES IF AB EIGHT FIVE
FOUR SIGNED INTO LAW LATER
THIS YEAR ANYONE WHO IS ON A
PROPERTY FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PRIOR CAN STILL USE THE ELLIS
ACT FREELY TO QUIT TO QUIT THE
RENTAL BUSINESS TOO OFTEN MANY
TENANTS IN RENT STABILIZED
UNITS LIVE IN CONSTANT FEAR
THAT THEY'RE BUILDING WILL
BE SOLD TO THE HIGHEST BIDDER
AND THE SUBJECT INDIVIDUAL
SHORTLY AFTER BY PASSING
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A CRUCIAL
STABILIZING EFFECT ON RENTERS
NO LONGER HAVE TO WORRY THAT
A NEW OWNER IS GOING TO EVICT
THEM WITHIN MONTHS OF CLOSING
ESCROW SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ONE TO JUST OVER TWENTY
YEARS TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED TEN UNITS IN LOS
ANGELES ALONE HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OFF THE RENTAL MARKET USING THE
ELSE ACT DISPLACING OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THANKFULLY THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES RECOGNIZES
THIS AND VOTED UNANIMOUSLY
TO SUPPORT AB EIGHT FIVE FOUR
YESTERDAY I WANT TO BE CLEAR
A USING THE ELLIS ACT DOES NOT
PRODUCE HOUSING IT PRODUCES
DISPLACEMENT AND WORSENS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS BY ALLOWING
REAL ESTATE SPECULATORS TO
REMOVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS DURING OUR I'M PRESIDENT
HOUSING CRISIS WE MUST EMPLOY
ALL OPTIONS AVAILABLE AND THAT
INCLUDES DEFENSIVE MEASURES
AGAINST DISPLACEMENT AND
HOMELESSNESS THE BILL THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A GUARD
RAIL AGAINST MORE VACATIONS
AND MORE PEOPLE LOSING THE ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IPHONE -- I'M ALSO
JOINED TODAY BY RETTELLE FOX
STAFF ATTORNEY STAFF ATTORNEY
AT THE TENDERLOIN HOUSING
CLINIC WHICH A CO SPONSOR RIGHT
HERE IN THE ROOM AND ARCHIE
SYLVESTER'S IMPACTED SENATE
WILL BE JOINING AT RALEIGH
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND JUST AS A
REMINDER -- EACH WITNESS WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO PRESENTS
-- -- FOR EACH WITNESS I THINK
THERE ARE TWO IN SUPPORT INTO
IN OPPOSITION -- WILL START
-- HERE IN PERSON GOOD MORNING
AND I USE THE MICROPHONE THING
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RICK
HEALTH PARKS I AM THE SENIOR
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY AT THE
TENDERLOIN HOUSING CLINIC FOR
I'VE BEEN EMPLOYED FOR THE
PAST TWENTY EIGHT YEARS I'M
ALSO A SAN FRANCISCO NATIVE
THAT GREW UP IN THE MISSION
DISTRICT SO FROM THE GROUND
FLOOR I HAVE SEEN THE CHANGE
THE DEMOGRAPHICS AND THE ABUSE
OF THE ELLIS ACT TO BASICALLY
CLANS AREAS WERE TRADITIONALLY
LATINO NEIGHBORHOODS I HAVE
PERSONALLY REPRESENTED CLIENTS
THAT LIVE IN THE MISSION
DISTRICT ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
THROUGH ELEVEN SIXTY ONE
ALABAMA SO HOT SPOT OTHERS
OTHER ELLIS ACT EVICTIONS
TAKING PLACE THERE IN THIS
PROPERTY THE ROOM THE REAL
ESTATE SPECULATOR CREATED NOT
ONE BUT TWO LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES WANT TO BE THE
MANAGING PARTNER TO INVOKE THE
ELLIS ACT THIS IS A BUILDING
AN APARTMENT BUILDING SIX UNITS
MULTI GENERATIONAL PEOPLE THAT
HAVE LIVED THERE FOR THIRTY
FORTY YEARS PEOPLE IN THEIR
SEVENTIES PEOPLE IN THEIR
EIGHTIES GRANDCHILDREN THAT ARE
ATTENDING SCHOOL IN THE MISSION
DISTRICT THIS SAME REAL ESTATE
SPECULATOR THAN CREATED ANOTHER
SERIES OF LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES AND AGAIN INVOKE
THE ELLIS ACT JUST AROUND
THE CORNER TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWENTY
FIFTH ST THAT BUILDING IS A
SIX UNIT APARTMENT BUILDING
AGAIN HOUSING LONG TERM LOW
INCOME LATINO FAMILIES THAT ARE
PART OF THE FIBER AND FABRIC
OF SAN FRANCISCO THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ALL WORKING
IN HOUSEKEEPING HOUSE CLEANING
MECHANICS OF MCDONALDS THEY'RE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THEY'RE
PEOPLE THAT WE NEED TO REMAIN
HOUSED AT ANOTHER COLLEAGUE
IN MY OFFICE IS REPRESENTING
THE SEVEN SECONDS WHAT THE
GIST OF IT IS THE TIME IS
NOW THE TIME IS NOT TOMORROW
OR NEXT YEAR BUT NOW TO STOP
THESE SPECULATIVE EVICTIONS
PRESERVE HOUSING AND STOP
THE PIPELINE TO HOMELESSNESS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WILL
NOW GO TO TESTIMONY BY PHONE
IS A MISTER ARCHIE SILVER
AT SYLVESTER I BELIEVE IT'S
TWENTY MY PHONE IN SUPPORT
I'M WHAT YOU SERVICE THE
ATTENDANT PLACING IN THOSE
CONVENTION IN LOS ANGELES ON
AUG THEN ASSISTED BY ONE OF THE
BILL'S SPONSORS THE COALITION
THE ECONOMIC SURVIVAL THEY
TRUST AND SELECTION THEN SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE WEEK LOSS
MAYBE TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
RENT CONTROLLED AFFORDABLE
UNITS IN LA WITHOUT APPROVING
THIS BILL MY NEIGHBORS AT
ODDS WILL BE ADDED TO THE
ALARMING NUMBER I LIVE IN A
FLOOD UNIT BUILDING IT'S VERY
CONTROLLABLE TO THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES BY HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
WANTING TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR OTHER IMMIGRANTS
THIS INVOLVING -- THE JUST
DIED AT NINETY EIGHT YEARS OLD
AND A CHILDREN L.
SOME TO SPECULATE COULD BE INK
HAS EVEN DRIED ON THE CONTRACT
ESCROW HOUSING COAL USE AND
THEY TOLD US THEY'LL BE ELLISON
AS SOON AS LA'S BECAUSE THEY
DEDUCTION PROTECTIONS EXPIRE MY
NEIGHBORS A RUSSIAN IMMIGRANT
JEANS AND A POLITICAL ARTICLE
FORTY TWO YEARS THEY JUST LOST
THE ONLY SON TO STOMACH CANCER
ON A BOTH NOT BATTLING CANCER
THEMSELVES AND ADDICTION WILL
LEAD THEM AND OTHERS HOMELESS
SO WITH NO COMPATIBLE HAVE
TWICE HOUSING IN THE AREA WILL
BE PUSHED OUT OF THE CITY MAYBE
EVEN THE STATE AND PERHAPS SOME
FROM THE STREET DEPENDENCE ON
ALL SOCIAL NETWORK OF FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS DOCTORS PHARMACIES
OUR SCHOOLS WILL BE DESTROYED
TENANTS WE WANT ASSETS TO
LANDLORDS NOW WE JUST THE
COUNCIL THAT NEEDS TO BE
REMOVED IT'S MOSTLY SPECULATIVE
DEVELOPERS EVICTING TENANTS
AND YOU WILL LESS OFF THE BLIND
THE BUILDING AB EIGHT VOICE
FOR IS A FAIR COMPROMISE THAT
PROHIBITS THESE OBJECTIONS FOR
FIVE YEARS ALTURAS SPECULATES
APPROACH TO THE BUILDING FOR
ME MY NEIGHBORS AND CALIFORNIA
RINSES PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB
EIGHT FORTY FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SINK TESTIMONY WE
WILL NOW BE GOING TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I BELIEVE
WHAT DECEMBER ONE IS DEBORAH
CARLTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
ARE YOU THERE DEBORAH
YES I AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR HI GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS DEBORAH CARLTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW THE ELLIS
ACT IS NOT ABOUT SPECULATORS
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS IN RENT
CONTROLLED CITIES THAT'S HOW
THE ORIGINAL LAW WAS WRITTEN
DESPITE THAT RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS BUT IT'S ABOUT RENT
CONTROL CITIES AND OWNERS WHO
CAN NO LONGER MAINTAIN THEIR
BUILDINGS LARGE BUILDINGS
DO NOT CONVERT TO OWNERSHIP
HOUSING AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CONVERSION
SOME OWNERS EVEN TENANTS COME
TOGETHER TO BUY BUILDINGS SO
THAT THEY CAN OWN THE HOUSING
AND MOVE IT AND WHILE CA DOES
NOT REPRESENT THESE OWNERS NOR
DO WE ENCOURAGE OWNERS TO SELL
AND GET OUT OF THE BUSINESS
OFTEN IT'S THEIR ONLY SOLUTION
IN SOME RENT CONTROL CITY'S
OWNERS CAN NO LONGER MAINTAIN
THE BUILDING WITH THE INCREASED
RENTS AREN'T ANSWER INCREASED
TAXES SEWER FEES AND OTHER
FEES WHILE FACING VERY LOW
RENTAL RATES EVEN MORE SO --
MANY OWNERS HAVE LIVED WITHOUT
RAIN FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS WITH
COBIT THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
MUCH TO PROTECT TENANTS IT
CREATED STATEWIDE RATE CAPS
AND WITH KOBE DID ALLOW TENANTS
TO CHECK A BOX AND CLAIMED
COBIT HARDSHIP BRING THEM FROM
RENT PAYMENTS AN INFECTION
THE LEGISLATURE PROTECTED THEM
EVEN IF THEY AS WE NOW ARE
DISCOVERING MAKE TOO MUCH MONEY
TO QUALIFY FOR RENT RELIEF AND
THEY'RE STILL NOT PAYING THE
RENT AB EIGHT FIVE FOUR AGAIN
ATTEMPTS A STRIKE ANOTHER BLOW
YOU WILL MAKE IT DIFFICULT
FOR THESE OWNERS TO SELL TO
SOMEONE WHO WISHES TO MOVE
INTO THE BUILDING AT -- NOW
THE ELLIS ACT PROVIDES TENANTS
WITH EXTENSIVE PROTECTIONS
WHICH WE AGREED TO IN GOOD
FAITH THE OWNER MUST GIVE A
ONE YEAR NOTICE AND PAY VERY
HIGH RELOCATION FEES AND SAN
FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE OFTEN
IN EXCESS OF FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS THANK YOU AFTER I'M
SORRY AFTER THAT THREE AND
SIXTY FIVE DAY NOTICE TO TENANT
-- CAN STILL CONTEST AND --
THE SALE OF THE BUILDING --
YOU KNOW WHILE OWNERS OF MAY
-- HAVE OWNED THE BUILDING
FOR LONGER THAN FIVE YEARS
THE NEW OWNER OR OWNER TENANTS
WHO WISH TO BUY MOVIE AND
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO SO
YOU CURRENTLY LIMITED THE
OWNER'S ABILITY TO SELL INTO
CONVERTING OR CLOSING -- IS A
DIFFICULT PROBLEM WITH A.
B.
EIGHT FIVE FOUR WE ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CARLSON AND
I WILL GO TO OUR -- SECONDS
-- WITNESS IN OPPOSITION CREAM
DRESSY AND IF YOU COULD KEEP
IT TO TWO MINUTES OF A GRADE
YES GOOD MORNING -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- CREAM GREASY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS HERE
TODAY IN OPPOSITION AB EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR -- EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR UP IN THE RECENT
CONSENSUS REACHED AMONG
TENANTS AND HOUSING PROVIDER
STAKEHOLDERS ON ELLIS ACT
REFORM IN TWENTY NINETEEN WITH
AB THIRTEEN NINETY NINE BLOOM
-- SPECIFICALLY AB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR SEEKS TO IMPOSE ONEROUS
REQUIREMENTS ON STRUGGLING
SMALL HOUSING PROVIDERS WHO ARE
OFTEN SENIORS AND INDIVIDUALS
OF COLOR BY PREVENTING THEM
FROM WITHDRAWING FROM THE
RENTAL HOUSING MARKET IN A
TIMELY FASHION DUE TO ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP THE ELLIS ACT AS
AMENDED WITH BROAD THE COLDER
INPUT BY SOMEBODY MEMBER
BLOOMBERG TV THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE PROVIDE THE BALANCE
MECHANISM FOR THE STRUGGLING
SMALL HOUSING PROVIDERS TO
UTILIZE AS A LAST RESORT TO
PROTECT THEIR FAMILIES FROM
FURTHER FINANCIAL HARDSHIP IN
SHARP CONTRAST EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR REGRETTABLY ISN'T
AN ARTFULLY DRAFTED LOPSIDED
PROPOSAL THAT FAILED TO
TAKE THE SENIORS INDIVIDUALS
OF COLOR INTO ACCOUNT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
-- AND HAVING HEARD FROM --
WITNESSES BOTH IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE WILL NOW MOVE
AND TO THE PUBLIC -- IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION -- AND
THE MODERATOR WILL LET YOU
KNOW HOW TO DO THAT AND AGAIN
PLEASE ASK THAT YOU STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
YOU ARE WITH ONE AND SIMPLY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE IN THIS IS
FOR AB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EARLY OPERATOR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NOW NINETEEN PEOPLE LOSE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR
ME JUST AGAIN ONE FORTY FOR
JUST A MOMENT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN HELLO JONATHAN GO
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT LINE SIXTY FOUR
RIGHT MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
IGOR TANGLED ON BEHALF OF B.
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
RENTERS COUNCIL ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
THE BERKELEY TENANTS UNION
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT AB EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTY NINE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
AND IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING
FOUNDATION IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU BLIND NINETY THREE
YEAH BETI PADHAO CALLING WITH
FEEL THE BURN SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ONE NINETY ONE
BY NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YEAH AT THE VERY IMPORTANT DOWN
THANK YOU LINE NINETY SIX HE
CALMLY WITH THE L.
A.
COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
LINE NINETY SEVEN
MY NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES SIR
YES MY NAME IS WELL HIDDEN I
WROTE IN GOSHEN I AM A HOUSING
ACTIVIST ON THE PENINSULA
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT LINE EIGHTY
SIX HI MY NAME IS ROBERT COOPER
FROM THE SEKHEMRE TENANTS UNION
STRONG SUPPORT LINE TWENTY VERY
-- THE SHANNON WITH HOUSING IS
A HUMAN RIGHT THE L.
A.
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RENTERS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT LINE NINETY TWO
MEMBERS NO HE ACTUALLY
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS PREDICTED
HE ENCOUNTERED PART THANK
YOU LINE ONE OH FOUR
YES GOOD MORNING JULIE
MARTINEZ FROM THE EAST SIDE
OF LOS ANGELES WOMEN'S HOUSING
ADVOCATES YES FIVE EIGHT EIGHT
THREE FOUR FIVE FOUR THANK YOU
FINE ONE OH SEX ELSA STEVEN
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT IN FAVOR
NINE FORTY SEVEN HELLO DAVID
IN CALLING FROM UNION CITY WHAT
WINE ONE OH TWO
HELLO THIS IS RYAN BELL
AND THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL COORDINATOR FOR
TENANTS TOGETHER AND I'M
CALLING FROM PASADENA
TODAY IN ÉC ASK STRONG
SUPPORT LINE THIRTY EIGHT
GOOD MORNING REX W.
HÌNH ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
LINE ONE EIGHT THING AND
THERE'S ACT BOWLING WITH
THE FAM THE -- CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
LINE THIRTY SIR
VENTURE MEMBERS BACKGROUND
WITH THEIR IN RENO SOCIUS
REPRESENTING THE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY HELLO
THIS IS FAR ABOVE COVER
WITH AS AND STRONG SUPPORT
LINE NINETY FIVE
NINETY THOUSAND ONE OPENED
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES OKAY HI
I'M MONICA MADRID I'M WITH
EIGHT AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY RANGERS TEMPLE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BLIND EIGHTY GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAYPAL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION
AND THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
OF GREATER LOS ANGELES
AND STRONG OPPOSITION
BLINDS THE
RECALLED LITTLE YELLOW
FOR NEAR IN SUPPORT
LINE THIRTY FOUR
HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
RYAN KINGSTON REPRESENTING
THE EAST BAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
AND STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
FINE SIXTY SIX
GOOD MORNING AMY SURE WITH
THE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION AS
CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
SEVEN GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TAIJI MIYAGAWA
REPRESENTING PROGRESSIVE
ASIAN NETWORK FOR ACTION IN
FULL SUPPORT AT EIGHT EIGHT
FIVE FOUR THANK YOU LINE SIX
YEAH A LOT FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
LARRY GROSS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
COALITION FOR ECONOMIC SURVIVAL
A CO SPONSOR OF AB EIGHT FIVE
FOUR WE STRONGLY URGE YEP BOND
AB EIGHT EIGHT FIVE FOUR ON
BEHALF OF THE OBJECTIVE ELLIS
LINE ONE OH THREE YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YES MY NAME
IS THE CHANGE IN OUR YARD
I'M NOT A MEMBER ON CALLING
FROM IS FOR CALIFORNIA
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
LINE ONE OH NINE AMY JUST
AFFECT CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR
LOCAL CONTROL WITH ALL THE COOL
NEW BILLS THAT LINE THE COFFERS
OF DEVELOPERS RATHER THAN LIVES
OF RESIDENTS IT'S GREAT TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THAT HAS POTENTIAL TO ACTUALLY
HELP PEOPLE YOU CLAIM YOU
WANT TO HELP I SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE FOUR THANK YOU
LINE ONE TEN
DEREK J.
TORN FROM EACH BAKER EVERYONE
IN OAKLAND AND I SUPPORT
WHY NOT ONE THIRTY ONE
BY ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES HI
MY NAME IS ON A DEAL -- D.
SHOW -- REPRESENTING COMMON
GROUND CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HERE TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT FOR
AB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
LINE THIRTY NINE
HI MY NAME IS BARBARA HOW
THEY WORK AND SELF PORTABLE
HOUSING TENANT ORGANIZER AT THE
COALITION FOR ECONOMIC SURVIVAL
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN
GOOD MORNING SHARE MEMBERS
TRYING TO GET THAT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION
AND WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND THE RECORDS
OF CITIES IN BERKELEY AND
SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT
BY SEVENTY
HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN JOY
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA MD
WITH THE ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE ARE
NOW IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU
LINE SEVENTY ONE HI THIS
IS JODY MARGOLICK BROWN
THE VICTOR THREE TENANTS
ASSOCIATION IN WEST HOLLYWOOD
WE FULLY SUPPORT THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED
WELL BORROWED WITH THE
CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE UNITED
FOR A SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
ONE FIFTY NINE GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS SUSAN MARSH AND
THE TENANT ACTIVIST IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT
LINE SEVENTY FIVE HI MY NAME IS
GISELLE MONTANA FROM WHITTIER
CALIFORNIA AS -- FROM EIGHT L.
EIGHT AND HOME DEFENDERS
LEAGUE WE ARE JUST STRONG
YES VOTE ON EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
FOUR LINE SEVENTY SEVEN HI
MY NAME IS EUGENE MAYES GUY
WITH COALITION FOR ECONOMIC
SURVIVAL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB DE EIGHT FIVE FOUR LINE
ONE ELEVEN GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS JORDAN GRINDS ON BEHALF
OF AN INSULT FOR EVERYONE
AND THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN EIGHTY TWENTY
TWO AN EIGHTY TWENTY FOUR
LEVINE ONE TWENTY FOUR HI
THIS IS CHRISTINE SHIMIZU I
AM REPRESENTING FEEL THE BURN
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT FIVE FOUR FINE
SEVENTY NINE AND I DON'T THREE
CO CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH
REPRESENTS THREE MILLION
REGISTERED DEMOCRATS AND MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHICH REPRESENTS
MILLION REGISTERED DEMOCRATS
AND BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE FOUR THANK YOU
FIND ONE OH FIVE
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
ON THAT TROUBLES ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC ADVOCATE WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FIVE FOUR THANK YOU
FIND ONE NINETEEN
GOOD MORNING MY NAME STATE
THREE ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN ADVANCINGJUSTICE
LOS ANGELES AND BACK INTO
ASIAN MARKETS BASED IN
OAKLAND WHERE FULL SUPPORT
AT EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
FIND ONE TWENTY TWO
GOOD MORNING JEANINE AND
CLOSELY WITH FAITH IN THE
VALLEY I JUST NEED YOU ALL TO
KNOW THAT WHEN FAMILIES ARE
DISPLACED FROM THEIR HOMES
IN SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA LINE ONE TWENTY
FIVE GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
JOSE LOPEZ I'M CALLING I'M
WITH EIGHT AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT AB EIGHT
BY FOUR LINE ONE TWENTY NINE
WHICH MAN CAN CAMPUS COME IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND SPECULATION
FINE ONE THIRTY HELLO MY NAME
IS NELSON WELL AS I'M SPEAKING
AS AN INDIVIDUAL RICHMOND CITY
COUNCILMEMBER FOR DISTRICT
ONE AND ALSO FOR EIGHT AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL LINE ONE THIRTY THREE
HELLO THIS IS ANDREW NOR WITH
THE TIGHT COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL FIND
ONE THIRTY FOUR GOOD MORNING
SASHA HARDEN INNER CITY LAW
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT FIND ONE FORTY ONE
GOOD MORNING CLOSER MERRITT
FOR CALIFORNIA LATINAS FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ABOUT THE -- THANK
YOU SO MUCH BEIN EIGHTY FIVE
HI MY NAME IS IS YET TO
YOUNG FROM THE SENATE
BARTENDERS UNION IN SUPPORT
FINE EIGHTY SEVEN
HI MY NAME'S KRISTEN LOPEZ
FROM SACRAMENTO I REPRESENT
AS AND ALL THE PEOPLE
THROWN OUT ON THE STREET
BECAUSE OF THIS SO WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT LINE NINETY
BY NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE NINETY FOUR GOOD
MORNING DAVID SHARPLES FROM
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA WITH THE
COMMUNITY GROUP AS AND WE
URGE A YES VOTE ON AB EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR LINE NINETY EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN
BONTA LINE NINETY NINE GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DOING CAMP WITH A CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
TRYLINE NINETY EIGHT AGAIN
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES HI
THIS IS ARVIND RAJAN KWONG
AS HOUSING NOW A STATEWIDE
COALITION ON HOUSING I'M ALSO
A PASTOR HERE IN LOS ANGELES
AND I'M OFF THE REPRESENTING
TODAY POLICY BEING AND
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL A STRONG
SUPPORTER AT EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR LINE ONE FORTY
SPECS HELLO GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS AMBERLEY LESLIE I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU KNOW IF
WE CAN -- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I KNOW SOME
REWARD HAS -- COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR A NEW
HE'S PUT A LOT OF WORK INTO
THIS EFFORT AND WITH A LOT OF
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS OUT THERE
TO REALLY TRY TO -- HAVE BRING
FOR A MEANINGFUL BILL THAT'S
GOING TO PROVIDE JUSTICE FOR
THAT MOST NORMAL CALIFORNIANS
THAT NEED IT THE MOST -- I
HAVE -- -- -- I'M VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS EFFORT AND
I WANTED TO JUST -- ASK A POINT
OF CLARIFICATION ABOUT THE
ELLIS ACT ON DOES IT CURRENTLY
AND AS I'M READING ANALYSIS
AND SEMI DOCUMENTARIANS IS
IT CURRENTLY ONLY APPLY TO
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE RENT
CONTROL OR DOESN'T APPLY TO ALL
JURISDICTIONS FOR COMMONSENSE
A QUESTION -- FOR CALIFORNIA
NEEDED HIS MICROPHONE IS
THE MICROPHONE YOU SOME THE
GOVERNMENT CODE SEVEN SIXTY
DOES NOT DIFFERENTIATE IT IS A
STATE WIDE AND CAN BE INVOKED
ANYWHERE AND I'VE SEEN IT
INVOLVED IN COUNTIES THAT DO
NOT HAVE RENT CONTROL BUT IT'S
RARE I MEAN THE REASON IT'S
INVOKED THIS TO PREEMPT LOCAL
RENT CONTROL GOT IT AND SO AND
DOES IT ONLY DOES THE ELLIS
ACT CURRENTLY ONLY APPLIED
TO RENT CONTROLLED UNITS OR
DOES IT APPLY TO ALL RENTAL
UNITS WELL IT APPLIES TO NEW
RESIDENTIAL UNIT OKAY THANK
YOU SO I SAW THAT YOU WERE
TAKING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ARE PROPOSED COMMITTEE MMS AT
LIMITED TO -- JUST ONLY UNITS
WITHIN A JURISDICTION THAT
HAS RENT CONTROL POLICIES IN
PLACE IS THAT CORRECT THAT'S
CORRECT SO -- AND HAVE BEEN
REPORTED AFTER YOUR DESIRE AND
THE COMMITTEE'S DESIRE -- I
THINK WE'RE AT A POINT RIGHT
NOW THOUGH IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
THE SAME PRINCIPLE HERE REALLY
APPLIES TO ALL RENTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA -- WE SEAT MASS
INCREASE IN PRICES THERE'S
A LOT THIS UNDERLYING -- WHY
THAT IS -- BUT FOR -- YOU KNOW
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHERE YOU'RE
WANTING TO SEE A LIMITED TO
JUST EXISTING RENTAL AND TO THE
RENT CONTROLLED UNITS WITHIN
A JURISDICTION THAT ALLOWS
FOR RENTAL CONTROL -- IT'S
ONLY A SUBSET OF OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT -- TO REALLY TRY
TO ADVANCE THE PRINCIPLES I
THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
UNDER THIS BILL -- I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE SEEN IT YOU KNOW MOVE
FORWARD A LITTLE BIT PRODUCT
NOT BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
MORE CALIFORNIANS WHO MAY NOT
HAVE THE ADVANTAGES OF LIVING
IN THE CITY -- WITH THOSE
PROTECTIONS OR I'D BE LIVING
IN A BUILDING THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO THOSE PROTECTIONS SO THE
LOOK AT THE LIMIT OF EARLY
FIFTY FOUR IS GOING TO BE ON
WHAT SOMEONE LIMITED -- SO IF
THAT IS SOMEHOW WE DON'T MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD AS AS AMENDED
-- BUT I JUST REALLY WANT TO
AGAIN COMMEND YOU FOR THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING -- I THINK YOU
KNOW TO A LOT WHEN I RECOGNIZE
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHERS
THAT MAKE -- INVESTMENTS THAT
COULD TAKE RISK ON THAT I I
BELIEVE ARE GOOD LANDLORDS
WHO WANT TO GET IN THERE AND
PROVIDE A MULTI UNIT HOUSING
FOR SO MANY THAT THAT NEED
ACCESS TO THE RENTAL MARKET I
ALSO COMMEND MANY OF THE GOOD
ACTORS THAT ARE OUT THERE --
BUT WHEN YOU'RE GETTING INTO
THIS OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW
YOU'RE MAKING A LONG TERM
INVESTMENT AND THE IDEA THAT --
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T LIVE WITH A
FIVE YEAR PROHIBITION ON ACTION
OF THIS NATURE DOESN'T SIT
WELL WITH ME -- IF IF YOU'RE
COMING IN YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE FOR SOME TIME -- THAT
YOU KNOW ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISABLED OR ELDERLY OR LOW
INCOME -- THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED IF YOU WANT MAKE IT LONG
TERM DECISION ABOUT WHAT TO
DO WITH THAT PROPERTY -- THAT
IS -- YOU KNOW ALL WITH STILL
WITHOUT WELL WITHIN YOUR RIGHTS
TO BE ABLE TO DO SO -- IT IS
JUST NOT FAIR -- ESPECIALLY
UNDER THE CURRENT LANDSCAPE
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WITH --
ALL YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER OTHER
OPTIONS ON THE OTHER OPTIONS
ARE -- YOU KNOW IMPOSSIBLY --
MORE EXPENSIVE -- HAVE A RENTAL
MARKETS AND THAT'S EXPERIENCE
THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE ON THE
STREETS RIGHT NOW TODAY ON OUR
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD TODAY SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING SUPPORT
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL --
YOU KNOW FOR THE AUTHORS SOME
WISHES AND I WANT TO THANK
I'M SURE WE WE HAVE A MOTION
TO BE THE SECOND MISCREANT
AND MR SEROTONIN SPEAK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
-- CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
HEARING AND HAPPILY JOIN YOU
IN THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL --
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING AND WORKING ON THIS
-- INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT POLICY
OKAY YOU GUYS CAN OKAY I'M VERY
IMPORTANT POLICY AND I WANT
TO THANK -- ARE LOS ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL WHO APPROVED --
UNANIMOUSLY I YESTERDAY TO TO
SUPPORT -- YOUR LEGISLATION AND
TO ALL OF THE -- RESIDENTS OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THAT
HAVE CALLED AND I WAS HEARING
SEVERAL MEMBERS ON THE L.
A.
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS WELL
AS SEVERAL OTHER DEMOCRATIC
GROUPS THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF
YOUR LEGISLATION AND THIS IS
A PRIORITY AND I ALSO WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE --
TENANT ADVOCATES THAT WE HAVE
MADE IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED JUST BE
INCREDIBLE HURT FULL STORIES
OF PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY
THAT ARE BEING EVICTED OUT
OF THEIR HOMES BECAUSE OF THE
ELLIS ACT OF MY COMMUNITY MY
DISTRICT IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GENTRIFYING AREAS WITHIN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES I HAVE
MET WITH RESIDENTS IN ECHO
PARK IN LINCOLN HEIGHTS IN EL
SERENO AND HIGHLAND PARK AND
ACROSS THE DISTRICT -- AND
UNDERSTOOD THEIR STORIES IN
TERMS OF HOW BECAUSE OF THIS
RAPID GENTRIFICATION IN MY
COMMUNITY FOLKS ARE COMING IN
THEY'RE BUYING UP BUILDINGS
THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE GONNA
KEEP THE RENTERS AND THEN
USING THE ELLIS ACT TO ACTUALLY
AFFECT THEM AND NOT HAVE THEM
RETURN I WILL SHARE A PERSONAL
STORY I USED TO BE A RENTER
IN HIGHLAND PARK SMALL LITTLE
ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT I WAS
PAYING NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DOLLARS AND WHEN I MOVED OUT
THAT APARTMENT BEGAN TO RUN
FOR TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO WAY
THAT I COULD HAVE AFFORDED THAT
RENTED MY OWN COMMUNITY AND
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO SURVIVE OFF A LIVING
OF THE MINIMUM WAGE IN THE
CITY OF LA WITH THE INCREDIBLE
COST INCREASE TO A QUALITY OF
LIFE HOW INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
IT IS TO LIVE IN THE CITY THAT
ONE HAS GROWN UP IN BECAUSE
OF THESE INCREDIBLE AS ARISES
IN IN RENT OR IS ACTUALLY MORE
EXPENSIVE TO RENT THEM TO EVEN
TO TRY TO PAY A MORTGAGE ON A
HOME SO IT'S THIS BACKWARDS WAY
IN WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE
SOLUTIONS TO AN INCREDIBLE
PROBLEM AND SO I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A AS A CO
AUTHOR JOINT AUTHORS TO HELP
YOU ENSURE THAT THIS GETS OUT
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND ON TO THE
SENATE AND MOVES FORWARD AND
GETS TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
BECAUSE WE CANNOT CONTINUE
TO DO THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AND EXPECTING DIFFERENT
RESULT IN THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE SOLUTIONS TO OUR HOUSING
CRISIS SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO MR SACK I THINK
YOU -- ARE BRINGING YOUR BILL
FORWARD TODAY AND ALLOWING A
GOOD DISCUSSION ABOUT IT BUT
ONE OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE WITH
THIS BILL IS HAVING COME FROM
AN AREA IN WORK AREA WHERE YOU
HAVE A LOT OF RENTAL HOUSING
-- A LOT OF IT IS PRETTY SUB
STANDARD IN A LOT OF IT IS
INDIVIDUALLY OWNED YOU'LL HAVE
SIX UNIT APARTMENT NINE UNIT
APARTMENTS THAT ARE OWNED BY
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOW ELDERLY
THEY THEY BOUGHT THE PROPERTY
WAY BACK YOU KNOW AND THE THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES AND THEY'RE
NO LONGER CAN TAKE CARE OF
THESE PROPERTIES -- AND FRANKLY
THEY WERE FOR THE PROPERTIES
ARE FIRE TRAPS -- THEY NEED
TO BE REMOVED AND REBUILT AND
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO DO
THAT BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
WHAT THE MOM IN THE POT IT'S
GOING TO BE WITH A DEVELOPER
THAT COMES IN AND TAKES SIX TO
NINE UNITS IN WITH A DENSITY
BONUS LAWS IS ABLE TO PUT IN
TWENTY FIVE UNITS SO WHAT IT
DOES IT HELPS ON THE SUPPLY
SIDE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THAT'S
THE PROBLEM WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH SUPPLY IF SOMEBODY GETS
EVICTED THEY SHOULD BE EASILY
ABLE TO MOVE OVER TO ANOTHER
APARTMENT BUT THOSE APARTMENTS
DON'T EXIST AND THE REASON
THEY DON'T EXIST IS BECAUSE WE
MADE IT TOO EXPENSIVE TO BUILD
AND GET THROUGH A PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA NOT JUST IN RURAL
AREAS ARE NOT JUST IN SUBURBAN
AREAS BUT IN URBAN AREAS ALSO
WHEN YOU HAVE TO SPEND FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A DOOR TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
UNITS THAT'S NOT AFFORDABLE
AND UNTIL THAT IS CORRECTED
WE CAN DO ALL OF THESE THAT WE
WANT IT'S NOT GOING TO FIX THE
PROBLEM -- I FEEL SORRY FOR
THE TENANTS I FEEL SORRY FOR
THE OWNERS BROUGH BECAUSE WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO WE'RE TRYING TO
PICK SIDES INSTEAD OF WORKING
ON WHAT THE REAL PROBLEM IS
AND THAT IS THE COST THAT IT
TAKES TO BUILD A UNIT YESTERDAY
I WAS SITTING IN A COMMITTEE
THEY PASSED THROUGH IN ORDER
ARE A -- THEY POTENTIAL BILL
THAT RAISES THE COST OF A
HOUSE BY THIRTY THOUSAND MORE
DOLLARS AS I AS YOU KNOW I
BROUGHT UP THE POINT YOU GUYS
YOU TAKEN FOR FOR HER FIFTY
THOUSAND TO FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR WE'RE
NOT GONNA GET WE'RE NEVER GOING
TO CATCH UP ON THIS PROBLEM IF
WE DON'T START FOCUSING MORE
ON THE SUPPLY ISSUE AND IN THE
PROCESS THAT'S RESTRICTING THAT
SUPPLY SO I APPRECIATE THESE
EFFORTS BY EVERYBODY TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THIS BUT KEEPING
PEOPLE IN SUB STANDARD HOUSING
BECAUSE YOU WE DON'T WANT THE
EVIL DEVELOPER TO COME IN AND
BUILD MORE HOUSING THAT IS
WHEN THEY'RE DONE BUILDING IT'S
JUST GONNA COST A LOT BECAUSE
IT STILL ISN'T GOING TO HELP
THAT THAT -- RENT -- ISSUE
MY KIDS LIVE IN LA THEY RAN
THEY PAY WAY MORE THAN I DID
EVER FOR A HOUSE MORTGAGE --
IT'S IT'S TERRIBLE AND IN ITS
UP INCUMBENT ON US TO REALLY
LOOK AT WHAT THE REAL PROBLEMS
ARE WORK ON THOSE AND AND NOT
MAKE IT WORSE BECAUSE TO ME
THIS IS THIS IS RESTRICTING
PEOPLE FROM TAKING WHAT ARE
SUB STANDARD NINETEEN THIRTIES
AND FORTIES STRUCTURES AND
KEEPING THEM BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GO THROUGH A PROCESS
TO IMPROVE AND UNFORTUNATELY
THAT PROCESS IS PEOPLE HAVE
TO MOVE OUT SO YOU CAN CLEAR
THE PROPERTY BUILD NEW AND BUT
THEY NEED SOMEWHERE TO GO WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THAT AND SO
BY KEEPING THEM IN PLACE WHERE
THEY ARE IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM EITHER IT'S JUST
GOING TO KEEP A SUB STANDARD
SIXTY NINE UNIT APARTMENT OR
A TOWN HOME OR CONDO IN PLACE
SO -- YOU KNOW FOR ME FOR ME I
HESITATE TO TO BE IN FAVOR OF
ANY BILLS LIKE THAT ARE TRYING
TO ADDRESS NOT THE PROBLEM
AND JUST MAKING IT SO THAT
WERE STUCK WHERE WE ARE SO --
I APPRECIATE IT THOUGH AND IT
AYE AYE WE DO AGREE WITH YOU
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WE HAVE TO GET
A HANDLE ON THIS -- BUT I JUST
FEEL LIKE WE'RE ATTACKING THE
WRONG WRONG PLACE THANK YOU CAN
I RESPOND TO THE CHAIR -- IF
YOU COULD RESPOND ARE CLOSING
AND TO THE CLERK OF COUNCIL AS
THEIR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AND MR
THANK YOU CHAIR REX OF THE
SOUNDS REALLY GOOD -- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
YOU KNOW MY MY FAMILY'S KIND
OF LIVED THE AMERICAN DREAM
IN MANY WAYS I WAS BORN INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND NOW
NOT ONLY BE HOMEOWNERS BUT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE RENTAL PROPERTY
MOST OF WHICH ARE THERE GOES
A SENIOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OR SECTION EIGHT FAMILIES --
AND IT OVER ME THINK ABOUT
THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
DO ON HOUSING THERE ISN'T ONE
THING THERE ARE MANY THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH IN
DOING THEM AT LEAST MAYBE NOT
AS FAST AS WE CAN OR SHOULD
BUT WE'VE ACTUALLY MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WHETHER
YOU KNOW SB NINE IN TERMS OF
DENSITY INTERFILM EIGHTY USE
AND WE'RE TRYING -- BUT WITHIN
THE LIMITATIONS OF WHAT WE CAN
DO WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS --
AND WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO DO
IS TAKE TWO STEPS FORWARD ONE
STEP BACK WEHRUM ON THE ONE
HAND YES WITH THE BILL MORE
SUPPLY BUT WE'RE LOSING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AFFORDABLE RENTAL
UNITS AT THE SAME TIME -- A
AND SO GETTING YOU KNOW GETTING
AROUND THE INTENTION OF ELLIS
I GOT THE I SEE THIS IS AS
SOLIDIFYING -- THE UNDERLYING
INTENTION OF THE L.
SECOND ATTEMPT BUT IN
PROTECTING RENTERS AND THERE
IS NO EXCUSE -- ESPECIALLY
IF SOMEONE'S OWN PROPERTY FOR
DECADES TALK ABOUT THE VALUE
OF HAVING THAT PROPERTY IF THEY
WERE TRULY GOT IT DECADES AGO
-- YOU KNOW FOR SOMEONE TO HAVE
SUB STANDARD HOUSING AND THAT'S
A PROBLEM WITH THE LANDLORDS
THAT THEY AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S ALWAYS IMAGES OF YOU
KNOW THE THE LIKE TO BE PUT OUT
THERE OF ALL MODERN POPS WHAT
HAVE YOU -- BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT IF YOU HAVE A PROPERTY --
OF THE IT'S YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE -- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
NOT JUST COMPLY ONCE YOU HAVE
AN ABILITY BUT TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT -- IS NOT JUST
LIVABLE BUT IS QUALITY AND --
YOU KNOW THE THE THE ANECDOTAL
OF ALL THIS IS GOING TO KEEP
PROPERTIES ARE BEING FIXED UP
WHAT HAVE YOU -- THAT THAT'S A
DECISION MORE OFTEN THAN NOT BY
THE LANDLORD AND THEIR PROFIT
MARGINS AND AND AND WHAT THEY
WANT TO SQUEEZE CENTER VENTURES
WE'VE SEEN THAT FAR TOO MUCH
AND IT GOES TO THE POINT OF
WANTING TO GET RENTERS OUT
SO YOU CAN BRING NEW VENTURES
AND AT MARKET RATES AND THAT'S
REALLY THE ULTIMATE SQUEEZE
THAT -- YOU KNOW AGAIN THE DAY
IS A DEBATE BETWEEN LANDLORDS
AND TENANTS POSSIBLY IF WE HAD
TO PICK A SIDE I'M GONNA PICK A
SIDE OF THOSE THAT WE COULD END
UP HOMELESS -- THESE ARE NOT
NORMAL CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS
OR AGREEMENTS WAS JUST THINKING
ON BUYING A SANDWICH FROM YOU
HERE'S A RECEIPT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOMEONE'S HOME IT'S WHERE
THEY LIVE AND -- YOU KNOW THAT
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND -- I
CONTROL HOMES IN LA THEY'RE
GONE NOW -- THAT'S A THAT'S
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND MORE
-- FAMILIES THAT WE HAVE TO
FIND HOUSING FOR -- IN IN AN
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE MARKET
AS EVERYONE HAS ACKNOWLEDGED
AND SO -- I COME I COMMEND
YOU AND I WOULD LAS YA SE IS
EVEN THE OPPOSITION IN THE
-- STATEMENT ADMITS IT'S A A
VERY SMALL NUMBER AN EXTREMELY
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF ACTIONS
THAT THAT'S THE CASE THE MOST
THE BIG DEAL IT IS TRULY A SORT
OF EXTREMELY SMALL -- IT WHAT
I WOULD SAY ON THE ONE HAND
WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL OF THIS
WAY OF STREAMING SMALL BUT TO
THOSE THAT ARE BEING AFFECTED
BY IT THE CHANGES OUR WHOLE
LIFE AND SO ON THE ONE HAND
I DON'T THINK IT'S GONNA BE
OVERLY BURDENSOME ON THOSE THAT
TRULY -- HAVE GOOD INTENTIONS
IN TERMS OF RENTERS ARE --
BUT LANDLORDS AND AND BUYING A
PROPERTY -- BUT IT CAN BE LIFE
CHANGER FOR THOSE OTHERWISE
WOULD BE LEFT WITHOUT A HOME
AND SO ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT IT
AND WOULD LIKE TO JOIN AS A
PRINCIPAL AUTHOR -- IF IF THE
AUTHORS -- PREFERENCE THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA ANY OTHER
QUESTION OUR CINEMA QUICK SILVA
CAN ON A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN
THE AMENDMENT THAT YOU DID
TAKE YES I AM HAPPY TO EXPLAIN
THAT SO WE TOOK THE AMENDMENT
TO LIMIT THE SCOPE ONLY TO
RENT CONTROLS OR SECTIONS AS
OUR CAL EXPLAINED SO NOW THIS
WOULD ONLY AFFECT TWENTY ONE
OUT OF FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND NOW
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE I WISH
YOU WERE BROADER SENSE I THINK
BY A SPECIFIC TARGET THE MOST
NORMAL RIGHT NOW FOLKS WHO ARE
RENT CONTROLLED UNITS RIGHT NOW
IS THE -- THE SPURNING APPROACH
AT THE MOMENT SO THAT'S THE
KIND OF THAT SEEMINGLY TOOK
SO THE COMMENTS THAT -- I
AM I'M GOING TO MAKE OUR ARE
MIXED IN THE SENSE THAT -- THIS
DECISION ON THE ALICE ACT IN
THE CHANGES YOU'RE BRINGING
FORWARD IS NOT JUST A ONE
YEAR DISCUSSION I WAS HERE IN
TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY THIRTEEN
TIME WAS VERY DIFFERENT AT
THIS TIME THE HUGE DIFFERENCE
THAT I HAVE SEEN UNDER HOUSING
JUST AS A WHOLE IS OF COURSE
THE SPECULATOR MARKET NOW
IF YOU TALK TO ME ABOUT THIS
ALMOST TEN YEARS AGO AND EVEN
WHEN I WAS ON COUNCIL IT WAS
A VERY DIFFERENT TIME AND TWO
THOUSAND FOUR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TWELVE WHEN I SERVED
WE WEREN'T EVEN TALKING ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS ON THAT SO SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO SERVED ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WILL KNOW THAT
BEFORE OUR EYES WE HAVE SEEN
ONE OF THE WORST CRISIS IS OF
OUR TIME AND THAT IS LITERALLY
PEOPLE NOT ONLY LIVING ON
THE STREET THAT ARE HOMELESS
BUT ARE DYING ON THE STREETS
SO AS A LEGISLATOR I HAVE TO
TAKE IN WHAT I CONSIDER PASSED
INFORMATION PRESENT AND THEN
LOOK TOWARDS THE FUTURE AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAY
ARE TO ASSESS SOME OF WHAT HE
SAYS REALLY DOES MEAN SOMETHING
WHICH IS WHAT ARE WE DOING NOW
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE UNITS AND
ARE THEY REALLY AFFORDABLE IF
WE CAN'T GET THIS PRODUCTION
MOVING AND WE COULD SPEND ALL
DAY AND WE DID SPEND MANY MANY
DAYS OVER THE -- RECESS TALKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH HOUSING PRODUCTION BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY ONE OF THE ONLY
WAYS THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO START TO SEE SOME TYPE
OF MARKET RATE AFFORDABILITY
IS BY HAVING THAT SUPPLY AND
DEMAND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS A VERY MEASURED POINT ON
ONE OF THE TOWARDS WAS THAT
WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE SITTING IN
RENTAL UNITS MARKET RATE NOT
NECESSARILY AFFORDABLE THAT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET IN THE
HOUSING MARKET BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO SALARIES MAY BE WELL
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT
THERE AREN'T THE UNITS FOR
THEM TO MOVE INTO AND THEY'RE
HOLDING THOSE UNITS WHICH
THEN -- PEOPLE WHO ARE STARTED
COMING OUT OF COLLEGE TRYING
TO GET IN THERE MOVED OUT OF
THOSE UNITS BUT IN THIS CASE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AFFORDABLE
UNITS I DID HAVE A MEET WITH A
FEW PEOPLE OF DISCUSSED IT AND
LIKE I SAID ON THE SPECULATOR
MARKET ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
NOT JUST SEEN IT AND RENTALS
OR SEEN IT AND HOUSING SOME
OF OUR SHOWS I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU WATCH BUT I KNOW A GOOD
DECADE DECADE AGAIN I STARTED
WATCHING I THINK IT WAS SIX
OR UPPER OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AND WE ALL THOUGHT IT WAS
KIND OF A FUN SHOW AND I DID
TO MAGNOLIA HOMES OR WHATEVER
THEY'RE DOING IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY AND THEN THEY
SELL IT FOR PROFIT THIS ALL
SEEMS THAT YOU KNOW BUT OUR
ISSUE IS THAT AS OUR SUPPLY
IN CALIFORNIA SHRINKS THIS NOW
EVEN WITH GREAT INTENTIONS IT
REALLY STARTS TO LIMIT FOR OUR
ENTRY LEVEL BUYERS SO I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TO GET
TODAY I DO HAVE CONCERNS --
BUT THE LAST THING I WANT TO DO
IS EXASPERATED A PROBLEM THAT
WE SEE BEFORE OUR EYES THAT WE
CAN NOT A RACE NO MATTER WHAT
WE WANT TO SAY WE HAVE A TENT
CITY NOW OUTSIDE ON FOURTEENTH
STREET ON THE PERIMETER OF OUR
CAPITAL THIS IS NOT HERE EVEN
IN NOVEMBER OR WHEN WE ARE IN
RECESS AUGUST SO THIS IS NOT AN
EXAGGERATION IT'S WHAT WE SEE
AND THE GREAT COUNTY OF ORANGE
COUNTY WHICH WE PRIDE OURSELVES
ON BUSINESS AND TOURISM WE
HAVE OVER THIRTY PEOPLE DYING
A MONTH ON THE STREETS OF
ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE TO DO
BETTER AND IF THIS AT LEAST CAN
KEEP PEOPLE HOUSE THAT ARE IN
THOSE UNITS THAT IS SOMETHING
I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT ON THE
OTHER HAND AS A TEAM HERE AND
IN OUR BUILDING WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO CUT OUT ALL
THESE BARRIERS TO PRODUCTION
AND GET BUSY BUILDING BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OKAY -- ED SMM RELIEF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE AND FEEL FREE
TO DRESS YOUR COLLEAGUES HERE
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION I REALLY
DO ENJOY -- A DEBATE ABOUT IT
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY A COUPLE
THINGS IS THAT UNDER THIS BILL
REFLECTIVE OF A COMPROMISE
THE LONG TERM LANDLORDS SAY
WHO OWNED PROPERTY SINCE THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES OR NINETEEN
SIXTIES STILL CANALSAT CAN
STILL USE THE ELLIS ACT THE
FIVE YEAR HOLDING PERIOD
ONLY APPLIES A FIVE YEARS OF
OWNERSHIP NO MATTER WHEN THAT
STARTED COULD BE NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE COULD BE TWO THOUSAND FIVE
AS LONG AS IT'S FIVE YEARS YOU
CAN STILL USE THAT RIGHT --
YOU CAN SEE THAT THE REBELS
ACT TO LEAVE THE RENTAL MARKET
SO WE BUILT THAT INTO THE BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT A LONG TIME
LANDLORDS WHO PERHAPS IN THE
CASE WHO ARE AGING OUT AND CAN
NO LONGER TEND TO THE RENTAL
PROPERTIES THAT'S FINE THAT'S
OKAY THE STILL CAN USE ALSO
ACT AND IF THIS BILL WERE TO
PASS THE STILL ARE FREELY ABLE
DO THAT THIS BILL IS TARGETED
TOWARDS PROPERTY SPECULATORS
WHO IN VERY RECENT HISTORY
BY A PROPERTIES IN WITHIN THE
FIRST ONE TO FIVE YEARS FOR
THEM LIKE THAT I REMEMBER WHEN
THE FLIP UNITS LIKE THAT IT
DOES NOT CREATE A NET NEW UNITS
THERE ARE NO NEW UNITS YOU'RE
CONVERTING A FORMER UNITS TO
MARKET RATE UNITS SO IN EFFECT
THAT WORSENS THE HOUSING CRISIS
UNFORTUNATELY AND I AGREE
WITH YOU I THINK THE IDEAL
WORLD IS WHERE WE A PLENTIFUL
SUPPLY WHERE IF SOMEONE WERE
UNFORTUNATE DISPLACED AND HAD
TO MOVE OUT FREELY AND EASILY
BE FIND ANOTHER PLACE OF
COMPARABLE STANDARD COMPARABLE
PRICE BUT THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW SO
THIS MEASURE IS NOT INTENDED
TO BE PRODUCTION MEASURE BUT
IT IS A DEFENSE MEASURE DEFENSE
AGAINST INCREASING HOMELESSNESS
THE GRANTING EVICTION AND ALSO
CLARIFIED UNDER EXISTING LAW
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S SOME --
MISINFORMATION OUT THERE UNDER
EXISTING LAW UNDER AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WHICH WAS PASSED
THE COUPLE YEARS AGO BY OUR
PREVIOUS HOUSING CHAIR -- THE
INTENT TO OCCUPY RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY BY THE OWNER OR THEIR
FAMILY IS STILL A NO FAULT JUST
CAUSE EVICTION AND WE INTEND
TO DEMONSTRATIVE CENSURE MODEL
RISEN TO PROBABLY SO SAVY THAT
FAMILY SOMEONE TO HOLD ON TO
THE SUB STANDARD UNIT AND THEY
WANT TO REMODEL IT THEY COULD
STILL UNDER EXISTING LAW VIC
FOLKS TO REBUILD -- BUT STILL
EXISTING LAW SO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS THAT THE FACTS ARE
OUT THERE THAT THOSE LONG TERM
SMALL MOM AND POP LANDLORDS
STILL HAVE THEIR RIGHTS THEY
CAN STILL -- UCL SACK BECAUSE
I THINK THE RESULTS -- SPREAD
THE SMALL MOM POOR MOM POPS
WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS
EXPLOITATION BY VERY LARGE
ACTORS AND I CAN'T REALLY
IMAGINE IN THE POST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WORLD OF MANY SMALL
MOM POP WINERIES CAN MUSTER THE
KIND OF CAPITAL RIGHT NOW IN
THIS HIGHLY COMPETITIVE MARKET
TO BUY A PROP IS A QUICKLY I
WE WANT TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF SMALL MOM POP MY LORDS BUT
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT VULNERABLE
TENANTS THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
TENANTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ARE NOT FACING THE REALITY OF
HAVING TO SLEEP ON THE STREETS
OR BECOME HOMELESS OR DESTITUTE
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM WE HAVE
SO AGAIN WHY THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE GREAT CONVERSATION TODAY
AND URGE YOUR IPHONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEAVE FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND FOR YOUR TENACIOUS
SUPPORT -- ON THE BILL AND --
AS MENTIONED THE BILL WOULD
LIMIT THE USE OF THE OIL SECTOR
THOSE PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
HAVE MAINTAIN OWNERSHIP FOR AT
LEAST FIVE YEARS -- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE TODAY
-- YOU KNOW THE L.
SECTORS ORIGINALLY ENACTED TO
LET PROPERTY OWNERS LEAVE THE
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS BUT
ALL TOO OFTEN WE DO KNOW THAT
THIS IS USED BY SPECULATIVE
REAL ESTATE BUYERS WHO BUY A
PRINT CONTROL BUILDINGS AND
THEN -- FLIP THEM ESSENTIALLY
THE CONDOS AND I WILL SAY I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS --
ON THE DICEY FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND YOU KNOW DO I
THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
IS AN ALL OF THE ABOVE -- THIS
PROBLEM IT'S AN ALL THE ABOVE
SOLUTIONS IS WHAT WE NEED
SO THAT DOES MEAN SUPPORTING
THINGS LIKE SUPPLY PRODUCTION
BILLS LIKE SB NINE AND OTHERS
THAT PRODUCE HOUSING AND SO
AS YOU ALL KNOW I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF THOSE TYPES OF
BILLS BECAUSE I DO AGREE MISTER
SECTOR WE DO HAVE TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING BUT IT ALSO MEANS
WE HAVE TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE ANNABLE TENANTS TO
AVOID A HOMELESSNESS -- AS A
MEMBER AT KALRA HAS SUGGESTED
SO I WILL BE -- SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY THE MOTIONS DO
PASSED AS AMENDED THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
-- WE HAVE A MOTION BY A SEVEN
MEMBER BOARD AND A SECOND
BY A SENTIMENT ON THE SEVEN
MEMBER CARILLO PLEASE TAKE
A ROLL WICKS HI HI THEY ARE
DON'T KNOW THEY ARE NO CARILLO
KOREA I'D GABRIEL GABRIEL
I KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
HIGHLY NO QUICK SILVA
COOK SILVA AYE WARD WARD I
THE BILL IS OUT
AND WE WILL GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
RIGHT YEAH YOU KNOW I
YEAH WE WILL OFFER
SOME SOLUTIONS
THE WORD
DO YOU
YEAH
WE ARE NOW BACK ON FILE
ITEM ONE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GARCIA EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY
TWO YOU MAY BEGIN S.
THANK YOU THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO WRITE
GRANTS TO LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO FACILITATE THE CONVERSION
OF MUNICIPALLY OWNED GOLF
COURSES INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OPEN SPACE AGAIN THIS
IS VOLUNTARY OR COMMUNITIES
THAT FEEL THIS MEETS THEIR
NEEDS -- I LIVE IN THE CITY
OF ALL OF OUR AGENTS WORKING
CLASS COMMUNITY YOU'VE HEARD
ME TALK ABOUT IT AND REGRET
LOW INCOME ON TOP OF THE LIST
OF WHAT KINDS OF THINGS YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE ON INCLUDING
LACK OF HOUSING LACK OF OPEN
SPACE A LOT OF POLLUTION OUT
THERE FROM MY HOUSE ALONE I
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN LOCAL GOLF
COURSES THAT ARE ALL SUBSIDIZED
BY THE TAXPAYERS OUT THERE --
AND LIMIT OUR AXES OUT THERE
JUST IN ONE CITY ALONE I HAVE
TO EIGHTY HOLD OFFICES NEXT
TO EACH OTHER ARE SEPARATED
BY A HALF A MILE OUT THERE
AND SO I THINK AREAS LIKE
THIS I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK THE SPACES AND STARTERS
RESTED NUMBER OF ISSUES OUT
THERE AND SO THESE AT INCIDENT
DOLLARS IDENTIFIED IN THE
LEGISLATION WILL GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ANOTHER TOOL IN
THEIR TOOLBOX TO MEET THEIR
RENOWNED NUMBERS WHILE ALSO
GIVING LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN A
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE HOMES OUT
THERE LAST RECESSION -- THE
CHURCH TALKED ABOUT HAVING THE
AT LARGE TOOLBOX OF SOLUTIONS
AND THIS IS JUST ANOTHER --
I THINK SMALL OF PIECES THAT
DISCUSSION AS WELL I HAVE A
LOT OF DENSITY IN MY DISTRICT
AND OTHER THAN BROWN FEELS --
THE ONLY OTHER SPACE BECAUSE
THERE TO LOOK AT OUR THESE
UNUSED GOLF COURSES I WALKED
BY ONE EVERY DAY I'M HOME --
AND I WOULD SAY WITHIN A MONTH
TIME I PROBABLY SEE SIXTY FOR
THE WHOLE MONTH THERE ARE IN
A COMMUNITY THAT HAS SIXTY
THOUSAND RESIDENTS OUT THERE
ALSO THIS BILL REALLY ALLOWS
THE SISTER TO RETHINK BOTH ARE
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS IN OUR
OPEN SPACE REQUIREMENTS FOR
VERY PARK OR IN MY COMMUNITY
THERE'S A GOAL BY THE GOVERNOR
-- THIRTY BY THIRTY WHICH
ATTEMPTS TO SET ASIDE THIRTY
PERCENT A WILDLANDS COASTAL AND
LAND AND WATERS AND OPEN SPACE
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S EVERY
CITY -- AND I THINK OPENING
OUR GOLF COURSES TO INCLUDE
OPEN SPACE AS A WAY TO HAVE
A RETHINK THAT IN THE URBAN
SETTINGS LIKE MINE I WANT ONE
MORE TIME REITERATE THAT THIS
IS VOLUNTARY AND JUST GIVES
LOCAL AGENCIES AND OTHER TOOL
TO RETHINK THEIR PROFITS BACK
HOME TO ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA I BELIEVE WE HAVE --
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
WANT TO REMIND WITNESSES YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES I WILL
BE KEEPING A TIMER SO TO KEEP
US ON TIME HERE -- AND OUR
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT IS
JOINING US BY PHONE ELIZABETH
HANSFORD ARE YOU THERE YES
FROM HERE MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
CAMP BURKE I RUN THE ORANGE
COUNTY YIMBY YES IN MY BACKYARD
GROUP CALLED PEOPLE FOR HOUSING
ORANGE COUNTY -- WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL AND AND
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FOR ARE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THIS IDEA -- SO CITIES IN
COASTAL CALIFORNIA ARE LOOKING
FOR SITE TO ACCOMMODATE ARENA
NUMBERS INCLUDING THE MUCH
LARGER REMEMBER THAT WE HAVE
GOTTEN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
-- ESPECIALLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- AND YET WE HEAR FROM
CITIES ALL THE TIME YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T WE CAN'T BUILD WERE BUILT
OUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY LAND WELL
HERE'S THE LAND AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONSIDERED
THE CITY ON SITE BECAUSE ONE
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
REDUCE THE COST OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING YOU KNOW THAT THE COST
PER DOOR IS TO USE PUBLICLY
OWNED SITES -- ANOTHER BENEFIT
IS THAT GOLF COURSES ARE LARGE
PARCELS AND WE CAN INTEGRATE
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING INTO
A LARGER HOUSING AND OPEN
SPACE PLAN TO CREATE NEW
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE RIGHT NOW --
CITIES ARE SCRAMBLING TO FIND
YOU KNOW SITE BUT THEY OWN SOME
OF WHICH ARE LIKE YOU KNOW IN
INDUSTRIAL AREAS THAT YOU KNOW
I MEAN WILL USE THEM IF WE HAVE
TO BUT WOULDN'T IT BE BETTER TO
HAVE YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES THAT
OFFER A RANGE OF HOUSING TYPES
AND PRICE POINTS AND TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE A NEW COMMUNITY
AROUND OPEN SPACE AND THAT'S
WHAT A GOLF COURSE GIVES YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO -- I WAS
A PLANNING COMMISSIONER FOR
THREE YEARS IN THE CITY WHERE
I LIVE AND -- THE PROJECT WHERE
WE FACE THE MOST OPPOSITION AND
WHAT COUNCIL WAS RELUCTANT TO
MOVE FORWARD WERE ONES WHERE
THEY SAID OH YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THAT WE
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T SEEN LEADS
AND THIS WOULD GIVE FUNDS TO
CITIES TO START THAT PROCESS
TO START PUTTING FORWARD THOSE
RENDERINGS WHAT IS THIS GOING
TO LOOK LIKE TO KIND OF GET
COMMUNITY BUY IT -- AND THEN I
GET THE LAST THING I'LL SAY IS
THAT YOU KNOW WE REALLY HAVE
TO ASK OURSELVES HOW WE WANT
TO USE OUR PUBLIC RESOURCES
DO WE WANT PUBLIC LAND AND
PUBLIC RESOURCES TO BE USED TO
SUBSIDIZE AN EXPENSIVE HOBBY OF
A FEW PEOPLE OR WOULD WE RATHER
USE THAT PUBLIC RESOURCE CAN
PROVIDE YOU HOUSING OPPORTUNITY
FOR MANY PEOPLE INCLUDING
MANY WHO BEEN SHOT OUT OF HIGH
OPPORTUNITY COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE GOLF COURSES ARE LOCATED
-- AGAIN WANT TO REITERATE WHAT
THE COUNTS -- TRY THAT SOME
WOMAN SAID YOU KNOW THIS IS A
VERY OPTIONAL IT'S AN OPTION
IT'S ONE TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX AT
THE TOP OF THE CITY COUNCIL THE
IF YOU COULD WRAP UP THANK YOU
OKAY YEAH THAT'S FINE
THANKS THANK YOU ANNA
OUR NEXT A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT -- DAVID BARBOZA
RIGHT
DAVID ARE YOU THERE
DAVID BARBOZA MADAM CHAIR WE'RE
SHOWING THAT HIS MIND IS ACTIVE
IN THE CALL WE'RE NOT SURE
IF HE'S THERE OR NOT DAVID IF
YOU'RE MUTED COULD YOU UN MUTE
LET'S MOVE TO ARM WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION WILL TRY
TO GET DAVID -- AFTER
THEM OUR FIRST WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION IS CRAIG KESSLER
CRAIG ALLOWED TWO MINUTES
MORNING THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY GREAT KESSLER
REPRESENTING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GOLF ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA WINES WITH
GOLF I'LL BE VERY WITH RESPECT
TO EXISTING LAW THERE'S NO
DISCUSSION ANYWHERE IN THE
ANALYSIS OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE CONVERSION OF PUBLICLY
ON GOLF COURSES THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION BY THE
BILL WOULD VIOLATE THE EXTENT
PARK PRESERVATION ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE IT WOULD
VERY LIKELY LEAD TO WHAT THE
STATE PASSED LIKELY NEED TO
YEARS OF LITIGATION WHICH WE
BELIEVE WILL LIKELY RESULT
EXPECTED NOTIFICATION OF IT SIX
SEVENTY TWO THE STAFF ANALYSIS
POSITS THE CONCLUSION THERE'S
NOT SUBSTANTIAL PRESIDENT THE
COMMERCIAL GOLF COURSES TO
OTHER USES IS BECAUSE THE PARK
PRESERVATION ACT THERE'S BEEN
A SUBSTANTIAL BAR UNDERSTOOD
IS ONE OF SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE SPECTER'S FISCAL
AFFECT THE MOST RECENT JANUARY
DRAFT OF THE BILL HAS DROPPED
A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR PRICE
TAG PRIOR SEPTEMBER NINTH
DRAFT AS NOW DRAFTED THE BILL
GIVES NO IDEA OF THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL'S INTENTIONS THAT'S
SOMETHING BLANK TO BE FILLED
IN LATER YES -- AS WE AND I
MIGHT ADD MANY THIS APOLOGIES
LONG GOLF COURSES THANK
LIKELY THE PARK RESERVATION
ACT APPLIES ANY PROCEEDS FROM
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE
MORE THAN EATEN UP BY THE PARK
RESERVATIONS ACT REQUIREMENTS
THE PROCEEDS OF THE TRANSACTION
WOULD HAVE TO BE USED BY THE
CITY'S REQUIRE SUBSTITUTE PARK
LAND AS SECTION FIFTY FOUR
OF FIVE THE PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE REQUIRES IN QUOTE BY
GENERALLY THE SAME PERSONS
USE THE EXISTING PARK LANDS
OF CELERY ALTHOUGH MANY AND
WE DO AGREE INTERPRET THAT TO
MEAN THAT A RECREATIONAL USE
ANOTHER COPY SATISFIES THE
REQUIREMENTS MURSCHEL HANDLE
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS DOES
NOT THIS REPRESENTS A SERIOUS
CONTRADICTION THAT AFFECTS
NOT LAW YES -- WITH RESPECT
TO THE ECONOMIC REFORMS OF
THE GOLF IS CHEN MY THAT I'M
QUITE FAMILIAR WITH THE TWO
GOLF COURSES IN ROUGHLY A MILE
AND A HALF AND REACH OTHER
AND BOTH PRODUCE SUBSTANTIAL
REVENUE NET REVENUES IN ONE
CASE WITH A CANYON LOS ANGELES
AND IN THE OTHER FOR THE CITY
OF DOWNEY ASSEMBLY SAY THAT THE
AUTHOR STATES OF THE NATIONAL
GOLF FOUNDATION REPORT YOU
COULD WRAP UP SIR THINKING TWO
THOUSAND SIX ASSEMBLY WRAPPED
UP BUT I THINK THE NEXT SPEAKER
IN OPPOSITION WILL SPEAK TO
THE ECONOMIC PERFORMANCES
THAT THIS RUSH TO YOUR BILL
AS LITTLE THE FALSE PROMISES
OPEN AND A COMMITMENT CENTRAL
CONTRADICTIONS IT CREATES MORE
PROBLEMS THAN IT SOLVES AND
ESTABLISH A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
FOR OTHER RECREATIONAL OPEN
SPACE THAT DOESN'T MATTER
AT THIS COMMITTEES BLOOD
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY -- MARC CONNELLY
ARE YOU AVAILABLE YOU OF
TWO MINUTES MARK BUT WHEN
YOU'RE HERE IN PERSON GREAT
I'M MARC CONNELLY WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA GOLF COURSE OWNERS
ASSOCIATION THE GOLF COURSE
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND HELLO DOES OUR
GOLF COURSE SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION -- MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS -- SB SIX SEVENTY
TWO IS REALLY A BILL ABOUT
A QUALITY OF LIFE THERE ARE
ROUGHLY THREE POINT SIX MILLION
GOLFERS IN CALIFORNIA -- AND
ROUGHLY -- EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY GOLF COURSE PROPERTIES
-- APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
OF WHICH ARE MUNICIPAL GOLF
COURSES AND IT IS THESE
MUNICIPAL COURSES THAT ARE
EXTREMELY AFFORDABLE THE
PROVIDE OPEN SPACE TO PROVIDE
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FAMILIES FOR FOR SENIORS AND
FOR A DIVERSE -- A SEGMENT OF
OUR POPULATION -- FOR EXAMPLE
MUNICIPAL COURSES ARE OFTEN
THE HOMES TO YOUTH ON COURSE
OR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GOLF ASSOCIATION'S JUNIOR GOLF
PROGRAMMING WHICH PROVIDES
GOLF FOUR FIVE DOLLARS OR LESS
FOR CHILDREN FROM AGES FIVE
TO NINETEEN AGAIN THAT'S FIVE
DOLLARS LESS FOR AN AFTERNOON
OF OF RECREATION AND -- AND
FITNESS -- THESE ARE ALSO
COURSES THAT ARE HOMES TO
THE FIRST TEE PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY -- THE FIRST HE
TEACHES CHILDREN IMPORTANT
LIFE SKILLS LIKE DIVERSITY THE
IMPORTANCE OF -- PERSEVERANCE
OF OF INTEGRITY AND HONESTY
AS WELL AS THE FIRST GREEN
PROGRAMS WHICH TEACH CHILDREN A
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
AND MATHEMATICS USING THE GOLF
COURSE IS A PLATFORM I'M AWARE
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
HAS VISITED A COURSE IN HIS
DISTRICT AND SEEN FIRSTHAND
THE DIVERT DIVERSITY ON THESE
COURSES I WOULD CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO DO SO
AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO HELP
FACILITATE A A COURSE VISITING
OUR DISTRICT -- WHETHER IT'S
DAD MILLER IN IN IN ANAHEIM
OR TORREY PINES DOWN IN SAN
DIEGO OR RANCHO DEL PUEBLO
IN SAN JOSE OR -- NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED OF THE GOLF COURSES
ACROSS THE STATE I LIKE TO
SHARE JUST VERY BRIEFLY SOME
IMPORTANT STATS ABOUT OKAY
-- SO -- PROCEED INTO MY
CONCLUSION IT AT A TIME WHEN
-- WE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING
ACTIVITIES THAT BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER TO BRING PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS TOGETHER
WHEN WE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING
OPEN SPACE RECREATION THIS
BILL ATTACKS OPEN SPACE IN
A TAX -- RECREATION OF THE
TAX DIVERSITY IT'S BAD PUBLIC
POLICY MANAGER KNOW ABOUT
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY I WILL NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS OPERATOR WILL
BE LISTENING TO FOLKS WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
AND WOULD LIKE TO REMIND YOU
OUGHT TO JUST PLEASE GIVE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
REPRESENTING ONE AND IF YOU ARE
SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING OPERATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
THIS LEGISLATION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
I'M GONNA GO TO LINE FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING TERRY NUMBERS BUT
ALL ARE QUITE AND WITH MY
HELP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH CENTER ALSO
KNOWN AS -- INTO PART THANK
YOU WELL I'D ONE SEVENTY
YEAH HI MY NAME IS LIEUTENANT
GENERAL I AM WAIT EIGHT ACTION
I'M CALLING AT THE PORT OF --
THE BILL -- TO YOU KNOW PUSH
FOR PUBLIC OUTING ON GOLF
COURSES COULD BE THEY'RE NOT
RECREATIONAL BAKER LINE THIRTY
TWO HI THIS IS GEORGE MARC SEAT
AT PERCY SILICON VALLEY THERE
IS HIGH DEMAND FOR ARE YOU
ABOUT WITH PROGRAMS AT PUBLIC
COURSES WE OPPOSE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY TWO LINE ONE THIRTY TWO
JEFF JOHNSON CALIFORNIA
GOLF COURSE SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY TWO LINE ONE TWELVE
HI SO IN THE ENERGY COUNTY
AND BE A STRONG SUPPORT ONE
ONE SIXTY ONE DAVID WHEATLEY
IN LOS ANGELES STRONG
OPPOSITION LINE EIGHTY SEVEN
IS THAT NAY YES MA'AM OKAY
THAT ELLIS -- MY NAME'S
KRISTEN LOPEZ EIGHT ACTION --
STRONG SUPPORT -- FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING OUT
ON THE STREET AND LINE EIGHT
AT THE CINEMA OF THE NOVEL
THE FOUNDER OF LATINO GOLFERS
ASSOCIATION RAISED IN PUBLIC
HOUSING STRONGLY OPPOSES SB SIX
SEVENTEEN FIND ONE FIFTY ONE
SACRAMENTO AND I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SEVENTY FIND ONE SIXTY EIGHT
HI DEREK J.
TORN FROM OAKLAND CALLING IN
SUPPORT WHY TWENTY SEVEN YES
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S TOM
EDISON THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PGA -- AND OUR ASSOCIATION
OUR MEMBERSHIP IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB SIX SEVENTY TWO
LINE TWENTY NINE HI JIM
KEREN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GOLF COURSE SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION PERCENT IN TWO
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS
WEREN'T STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
PARDON ME LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
RICHARD HARRIS THERE'S
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC GOLF
ALLIANCE WE HAVE MORE
THAN SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU WHY SEVENTY FIVE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NINE ONE SIXTY NINE GOOD
MORNING AGAIN SHARON
MEMBERS JORDAN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF PENINSULA FOR
EVERYONE IN AB TWENTY TWO
IN STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY
SIX SEVEN TWO FIND FORTY TWO
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOE
HOUSTON WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GOLF ASSOCIATION
THAT INCLUDES OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
OUR ORGANIZATION IS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL LINE
ONE SEVENTY WIDE GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ANYMORE MINISTER
WITH THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
FOR BETTER HEALTH THROUGH
CALL DOCTOR'S ORDERS PLAY
GOLF AND WE HOPEFULLY OPPOSE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SIX SEVENTY
TWO ONE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
FANCIED ELIZONDO'S FROM
SOLANO CANYON IN LOS ANGELES
FOUNDING MEMBER OF LOSS OF
LIFE BEYOND OFFERS ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SIX SEVENTY
TWO FIND ONE SEVENTY FIVE
HEY GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ALFRED Q.
LIVING IN BERKELEY I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
LINE ONE SEVENTY THREE
FIND ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AND A FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO COMMENT ON THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ONE PERSON WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK PARDON ME
WE HAVE TO ONE SEVENTY FIVE
ONE FIVE YOUR LOG HI THIS
IS MIKE DEFINITELY HEAR
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SIX SEVENTY TWO AND A MEMBER
OF THE HOME DEFENDERS WEEK
ONE ONE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
HI THIS IS SUSAN KIRSCH
WITH CATALYST FOR LOCAL
CONTROL IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL FIND ONE SEVENTY
SIX WHEN DO NOT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GOLF ASSOCIATION
PGA IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB SIX SEVENTY TWO
I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
THAT SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU OPERATOR -- ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE AUTHOR MR WARD THANK YOU
ONE OF THEM THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD OUT
NOTHING THAT I SEE HERE IN
THIS BILL IS COMPELLING THE
-- THAT OF THE CLOSURE AND
RE USE OF OF GOLF COURSES BUT
RATHER AT LEAST THE CONTROL TO
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
OWNED THE GOLF COURSES AND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS SETTING UP AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT
EASIER TO MAKE THAT TRANSITION
HAPPEN WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
REALLY TRAINING THIS TOWARDS
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE KIND OF
FOR TWENTY FIVE PERCENT -- LOW
INCOME HOUSING ON SITE AS WELL
AS PRESERVATION OF OPEN SPACE
AS WELL I THINK IT'S A REALLY
-- TAILORED WAY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HELP FOR
USE THINGS THAT ARE PROBABLY
FEELING OR OTHERWISE UNDER
PERFORMING -- THAT JUST GIVES
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL YOU MUST WHERE
NECESSARY TO I THANK YOU SIR
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT IN FACT
I KNOW A COMMUNITY THAT IS
HAVING A GOLF COURSE LOOKED AT
BY A DEVELOPER TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IT'S
A PRIVATE COURSE THOUGH AND
IT STRUGGLING -- WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS MUNICIPAL
COURSES GOVERNMENT ON COURSES
CITY OWNED OR WHATEVER A LOT
OF THOSE COURSES ARE LOCATED
IN AREAS WHERE WE HAVE OTHER
BILLS THAT ARE SAYING HEY WE
DON'T WANT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILT THERE BECAUSE IT'S NEAR
FREEWAY FOR ITS NEAR TRANSIT
QUARTER THAT -- THERE WHICH
IS A HIGH DENSITY A LOT OF
-- -- -- WHAT THEY THINK WILL
MAKE IT WORSE FOR FOLKS THAT
LIVE IN THOSE AREAS -- HEALTH
WISE AND EVERYTHING ELSE IT
ALSO FLIES IN THE FACE OF THE
EFFORT TO FIND SOMETHING FOR
OUR USE ESPECIALLY IN INNER
CITIES TO HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
-- JUST SITTING AROUND -- JUST
NOT HAVING ANY RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AT ALL I'VE
SEEN A HUGE EXPANSION IN THE
AMOUNT OF KIDS THAT ARE BEING
INVOLVED IN GOLF SEEMS LIKE
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL NOW HAS A
GOLF TEAM THEY DIDN'T USED TO
HAVE THAT AND AND I'VE HAD AN
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DO THESE CONVERSIONS IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY YOU DON'T NEED
A GRANT FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT ALTHOUGH IT WOULD HELP
IF THEY EVER GET TO THE PART
WHERE THEY HAVE FEES BUT WHEN
YOU TAKE THE PRACTICALITY OF
TAKING A LARGE OPEN SPACE AREA
AND THEN TURNING IT INTO HIGH
DENSITY -- ESPECIALLY IN IN
THERE IS THE INNER CITY AREAS
THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
-- OF OF HAVING THE -- MASTER
PLANNED COMMUNITY CONCEPT
DOWNTOWN BUT WE IN MASTER
PLANNED COMMUNITIES YOU'LL
NEVER GET PAST SEQUEL C.
WILL NOT ALLOW THAT TYPE OF
DENSITY TO BE ADDED IN TO WHAT
WAS ALREADY APPROVED BUY A CD
FOR MASTER PLANNED COMMUNITY
SO THE INFRASTRUCTURE IT THAT'S
BUILT IN IT IS NOT BUILT TO
HANDLE SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND
IT'LL NEVER GET TO SEE WHAT
UNLESS WE CREATE MORE SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS FOR THOSE THINGS
AND THEN YOU'RE DEFEATING THE
PURPOSE OF SEQUEL IN THE FIRST
PLACE SORRY EVERYTHING WE'RE
DOING IS IS IT SEEMS COUNTER
INTUITIVE TO SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND
I KNOW THAT I'VE THE GOOD WILL
OF OF TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
I'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THAT
THE PROCESS IS WHAT'S KILLING
THIS PROJECT THAT I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THEY HAVE
THE BACKING THEY HAVE THE THE
FINANCES THEY CAN'T GET THROUGH
THE PROCESS THEY CAN'T GET
THEIR SEQUEL AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO NOT BE ABLE TO BUILD
OUT PROJECT SO WHAT IT'S GOING
TO BE IS A BUNCH OF VACANT
LAND WHICH LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
OKAY WITH VACANT LAND BUT YOU
KNOW UNTIL WE ADDRESS THOSE
OTHER THINGS GRANTS ARE FINE
BUT IF IF WE DON'T IF WE
DON'T FIX THE PROCESS THEY'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO BUILD
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR -- JUST TO
THE AUTHORED FOR CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES THIS ONLY APPLIES
TO -- GOLF COURSES THAT ARE
OWNED BY CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES IT IS
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT VOLUNTARY
-- OFTENTIMES THESE GOLF
COURSES BECAUSE THOSE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES MORE MORE MONEY
TO JUST SIMPLY UP KEEP THEM
WHILE THEY ARE UNDER UTILIZED
-- VOLUNTARY NOT MANDATE AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATED TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT MUST BE AFFORDABLE LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND ALSO FIFTY
PERCENT AT LEAST HAS TO REMAIN
AN OPEN SPACE -- LIKE A PARK
SOMETHING SIMILAR OF COURSES
ARE CURRENTLY NOT NECESSARILY
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC IN
WHICH THEY ARE LOCATED AND
CORRECT CORRECT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH THAT
WILL LET YOU CLOSE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CAREER GARCIA THIS THIS
BILL IS PERMISSIVE AT THE ONLY
TALK ABOUT QUALITY OF LIFE
THERE'S NO PART OF YOUR LIFE
AND A HALF ACRES UPON ACRES
FENCED UP AND MY COMMUNITY
MEMBERS CANNOT ACCESS THAT
OPEN SPACE IN ANY CAPACITY EVEN
AT THE FIVE DOLLARS YOU KNOW
AND THREE FEET IT'S ACTUALLY
TEN DOLLARS SYMBOL OF ART AND
THAT'S STILL NOT AFFORDABLE ON
A REGULAR BASIS IN MY COMMUNITY
IT FEELS PRETTY INSULTING
WHEN I WALK BY THEIR -- AND I
HAVE KIDS NEXT DOOR IN PLAIN
UNDERNEATH -- EDISON FENCE IT
IS A LINE IN THE DIRT -- WHO
ARE HUNGRY FOR OPEN SPACE THAT
WE CANNOT OPEN THE SPACE --
THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE TO BUILD
AN AND MY COMMUNITY WE HAVE
DONE THE LOSSLESS WE HAVE THAN
THE EIGHTY USE WE HAVE BEEN
THE FOR FUN ALL THE IDEAS WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING HERE WE'VE
BEEN DOING IN MY COMMUNITY
AND WE NEED TO GET CREATIVE
IT'S INSULTING WHEN I HAVE
A LIMITED CONTRACT CITY WORD
LIMITED BUDGETS AND THEY'RE
SUBSIDIZING THIS GOLF COURSE
OUT THERE AND SO WE NEED TO GET
CREATIVE THIS IS MODEST IF IT
DOES NOT WORK FOR A COMMUNITY
THEY DO NOT NEED TO PARTAKE
IN THIS FOR MY COMMUNITY NEEDS
TO SEE DOLLARS SO THAT THEY
COULD I START TO DO THE HOURS
THE COMMUNITY AND CREATE A
COMMUNITY BASED PLAN FOR WITH
THAT I WOULD BE BETTER USE
FIND THAT'S PART OF WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE I THINK I
BELIEVE A MOTION BY MISTER WARD
IN THE SECOND A -- MISCREANTS
-- WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR IT AS
DISCUSSED IN THE LAST DEBATE OF
THE LAST BILL THE NEED FOR --
ALL DIFFERENT TYPES OF CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO THE HOUSING
CRISIS BETWEEN -- EXISTS IN
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY SO WITH
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY THE MOST AS DO
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT PLEASE
TAKE A ROLL WICKS I SEE ARE
TO NOTE HERE TO KNOW CARILLO
THIRTY I GABRIELLE KALRA
KILEY HIGHLY NO QUICKSILVER
KIRK SILVA I WORK WORK HI
THE BILL'S ON COFFEE FORMER
MANAGER MANY COMMOTION FOR
ITEM TWO EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
TO MOVE THE BILL IS THAT --
BLOOMS SILVA YES I DID A DAY
WE DO HAVE MOTION WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR INDIA I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE A SECOND ON IT AND WE
DO HAVE A SEVEN NINE OKAY YEAH
WHAT WE'LL DO I THINK IT'S OPEN
RIGHT NOW WILL DO AT THE END
WE CAN GO NOW TO -- LET'S SEE
WE ARE ON FILE ITEM FOUR I
BELIEVE MISTER SALAS AB NINE
ONE SIX THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I'LL
BE BRIEF THIS BILL HAS --
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION BUT
LET ME JUST SAY THAT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE ONE SIX IS JUST
LOOKING TO REMOVE BARRIERS
FOR THE CREATION OF ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS BY ADDING
ADDITIONAL BEDROOMS TO YOUR OWN
EXISTING HOUSE -- WITH THAT I
DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF CAPABLE WITH CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND
CHARLES KAHN WHO IS AN EIGHTY
YOU ARCHITECT IN THE STATE SO
IF YOU LIKE TO LIVE UNDER THEM
THAT'S BECAUSE GREAT I THINK
I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO WITNESSES
-- JOINING BY PHONE KATE BELL
AS WITNESS NUMBER ONE AND
KATE YOU WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KATE BELLAMY HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSOR OF AB
NINE SIXTEEN AS WELL AS THE
APARTMENTS LOCATION OF BREAKING
OFF ANYMORE I WILL BE BRIEF
LIKE A PARK I THINK IN THE
COMMITTEE SHOPS FOR THEIR WORK
AND A LOT OF NUMBER SALAS FOR
OFFERING OF LEGISLATION THAT
WILL STREAMLINE THE CREATION
OF MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE UNDER
CURRENT STATUTE ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY USE AND JUNIOR EIGHTY
YEARS IT'S EXEMPTION A PUBLIC
HEARING PROBLEMS BUT OFTENTIMES
CREATE UNWARRANTED DELAYS
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE US AN
EXEMPTION FOR THE ADDITIONAL
BEDROOM SPACE ALLEVIATING THE
BURDEN FOR A PUBLIC HEARING
ESPECIALLY IN THIS COLD
ENVIRONMENT WILL RESULT IN THE
CREATION OF MORE HOUSING MUCH
MORE RAPIDLY TENANTS FROM JUST
NORTH STATE GROWING FAMILIES
WHO DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO MOVE
PAPAMOA ALL BENEFIT FROM THE
SPELL ADDITIONALLY EIGHTY NINE
SIXTEEN WOULD INCREASE THE
HEIGHT LIMITATION FROM SIXTEEN
TO EIGHTEEN FEET FOR EIGHTY
YEARS BUT ARE ON EXISTING
MULTI FAMILY MULTI STOREY SIX
MO THANKS TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
BUILD TWO STORY EIGHTY YEARS
OF LAW CONVERT ARM KICKED
COOPER CROTCHES INTERMEDIATE
BOTH OF THESE POLICY CHANGES
WILL HELP OUR MEMBERS AND
OTHERS DELIVER MORE POLITICAL
POPULOUS STATE THANK YOU AND
ARE EXPECTED -- JOB THANK YOU
AND OUR WITNESS NUMBER TWO
CHARLES CONNOR YOU THEIR TRIALS
YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES YES
I'M HERE THANK YOU BUT I'M SURE
-- GOOD MORNING THAT INSURED
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
CHARLES KAHNEMAN CALIFORNIA
ARCHITECT ON THE PRINCIPLE
OF STUDIO KTA AND SERVE
AS A MEMBER OF THE CITY OF
BERKELEY CA DO YOU TASK FORCE
AS WELL AS CHAIR OF THE CITY
OF BERKELEY ZONING BOARD I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF
OF AB NINE SIXTEEN ALTHOUGH
IT'S LEGISLATIVE IMPACT IS
MINOR A FEW ADJUSTMENTS TO
EXISTING LEGISLATION ITS
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON THE STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS IS HUGE AB
NINE SIXTEEN BUT THE FILLETING
HIGHLY AFFORDABLE RETROFITS
OF EXISTING HOUSING STOCK
IN ORDER TO SIMPLY PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL VETERANS HAVE A
POSITIVE EFFECT ON THE CRISIS
ON A PAR WITH FAR MORE COMPLEX
LEGISLATION THIS REPRESENTS
CUTS DINES TO THE DOLLARS TO
MAKE CONSTRUCTION THE GREAT
HOUSING WHICH IS NATURALLY
MORE AFFORDABLE WITHOUT THE
NEED FOR PURE BUREAUCRATIC
OVERSIGHT OVER PUBLIC FUNDING
ADDITIONALLY AB NINE SIXTEEN
BY RAISING THE HEIGHT FOR
EIGHTY YEARS AN EXISTING MULTI
FAMILY MULTI STORY SIDES TO
CREATE FROM SIXTEEN STATES
JUST EIGHTEEN COURAGE'S MORE
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE MORE
AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT WE KNOW
YOU SUPPORT AND BY ALLOWING
PROJECTS TO GO UP SAID ABOUT
NOT THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
POINT BY GOING UP INSTEAD
OF OUT IT HAS THE POTENTIAL
PRESERVING MUCH NEEDED GREEN
SPACE THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
BE LOST IT'S YOUR CHANGES
WILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS
ON THE HOUSING CRISIS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
FOR THEM RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YEAR I THOUGHT TODAY THANKS
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SINK
TESTIMONY FROM BOTH WITNESSES
I BELIEVE WE HAVE NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION LET'S TURN IT
OVER TO THE OPERATOR -- IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE SIXTEEN BY A SEVEN
MEMBER SALAS -- OPERATOR --
PLEASE -- OPEN UP THE LINES
AND PLEASE REMEMBER TO JUST
DO YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
YOU'RE REPRESENTING ONE AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSE POSITION
THANK YOU MANAGER FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
MADAM CHAIR IT APPEARS NO
ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK PARDON ME I
STAND CORRECTED JUST A MOMENT
AND OUR APOLOGIES IF
ANYONE WISH TO A SIGNAL
-- COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE OF SIGNALED THEY
WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT
GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE DAVID
WHEATLEY IN LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG OPPOSITION LINE FIFTY
TWO GOOD MORNING TERRY NUMBERS
THAT THERE ARE QUITE A WITH
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC ON BEHALF
OF THE SAME PRINCIPLE PLANNING
IN URBAN RESEARCH CENTER OPEN
UNDER SPUR IN SUPPORT THE
ISSUE ONE ONE SEVENTY FIVE
IT OPERATES YOU I LIVE IN
A AB YOU I'M IN THE PORT
THANK YOU FIND ONE FOURTEEN
ONE ONE FORTY YES THIS IS
JAY GARFINKEL A MEMBER OF THE
ALAMEDA CITIZENS TASK FORCE
AND CATALYSTS FOR CHANGE I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
LINE ONE EIGHTY
HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN
JOY CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIAN B.
WE WANT TO THANK THE SPONSORS
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
OVER THE YEARS AND WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
AND THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
BY CLASS PRIVATE THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE A MOTION
LET'S CREATE A SECOND MISS
CLARK SILVA -- I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR -- FOR THE BILL
-- THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SIMPLY COMMITTEE AND LOCAL GOV
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL WE
NEED TO -- EIGHT OF SOLUTIONS
TO SOLVE OUR HOUSING CRISIS
THIS IS AN EASY ONE SO WE
SHOULD MOVE THE BILL FORWARD
WICKS FIVE FIVE THEY ARE CO
OPERATING DURING THIRTY OKAY
I GABRIELLE KALRA KILEY KILEY
I QUIKSILVER KIRK SILVA I WORK
AT THE BILL'S ON CALL THANK
YOU MISTER SALAS NEXT UP
WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY TWELVE OH SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I AM AB TWELVE OH SIX ALLOWS
A COMMUNITY LAND TRUST TO KEEP
THEIR -- WELFARE EXEMPTION
UNTIL RESIDENTS INCOME EXCEED
A HUNDRED AND FORTY PERCENT
A LAND TRUST PROVIDE UNIQUE
MODEL TO SOLVE -- OR ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS AND UNLIKE
-- AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE
BY LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT LAND TRUST CAN LOSE
THEIR WELFARE EXEMPTION IF A
SINGLE RESIDENT -- MAKES MORE
THAN EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
AREA MEDIAN INCOME -- IN AB
TWELVE OH SIX SIMPLY PROVIDES
PARITY CELEB LANCHESTER
TREATED LIKE OTHER FORMS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- AND --
I THINK IT HAS APPROPRIATE
SAFEGUARDS ONCE YOU GO OVER
HUNDRED FORTY PERCENT -- THEN
-- THIS EXCEPTION DOES NO
LONGER APPLIES AND WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS CRISTINA
OAKFIELD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS PAGE THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
YOUR FOOTWEAR ONE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION -- AS
YOU MENTIONED CRISTINA IS OUR
ONE AND ONLY -- WITNESS TODAY
AND -- KRISTIN IF YOU'RE THERE
YOU WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
OUR GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA OAKFIELD AND I'M
AN ATTORNEY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK AND CALIFORNIA THE L.
T.
ACTION TODAY B.
TWO NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDE OVER TWENTY FIVE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST OR STEAL
KEYS AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVELY HOLDING
OVER WELL OVER TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION IN COMMUNITY
ASK THAT FOR PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CALIFORNIANS
ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS THE L.
T.
R.
EXCEPTIONALLY EFFECTIVE HOWEVER
COMPARED TO OTHER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS FIELD
HE'S FACE SOME DISADVANTAGES
THIS BILL AB TWELVE THOSE
SIX SPEAK TO ADDRESS ONE
OF THOSE DISADVANTAGES WITH
REGARD TO PROPERTY TAXES AND
THE TECHNICALLY THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION CODE SECTION
TO FOURTEEN JEAN WELFARE
EXEMPTION -- BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY THREE PASS WHICH ALLOWS
PROPERTIES FINANCED BY LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT TO
KEEP THEIR WELFARE EXEMPTION
EVEN AFTER RESIDENTS INCOME
INCREASES UP TO A HUNDRED
AND FORTY PERCENT OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOMES ARE AM I A
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST MODEL IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THAT BILL THERE
FOR OUR RESIDENTS FACE MUCH
STRICTER LIMITS ON THEIR INCOME
WHAT THAT MEANS PRACTICALLY
SPEAKING IS THAT S.
C.
O.
T.
ME MAY HAVE TO PASS ON HIGHER
TAX BILL ON TO RESIDENTS TO
GO OVER THE INCOME LIMIT FOR
EXAMPLE SOMEONE WHO INCOME
GOES UP TO EIGHTY TWO PERCENT
AM I COULD CUT AND YOU HAVE
TO PAY HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS
MORE IN RENT -- IN SOME CASES
THE FIELD HE COULD COMPLETELY
LOSE THEIR WELFARE EXEMPTION
IF THAT HAPPENS AND EVERYONE
HAS TO PAY MORE RIGHT EVEN THE
LOWER INCOME FOLKS -- SO AB
TWELVE ESSEX RECTIFIED THIS
UNFAIR SITUATION WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB TWELVE SX I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT MEMBERS MAY HAVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TWO
MINUTES ON THE DOT TESTIMONY
APPRECIATED -- AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONES OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT AGAIN
PLEASES YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENTING ONE AND
IF YOU OPPOSE OR SUPPORT
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
SIXTY ONE DAVID WHEATLEY
IN LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT
WHY NOT ONE EIGHTY ONE
BRUCE FALL CARE C.
O.
P.
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
GOP NETWORK IN SUPPORT
FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
I'M SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH
TO SPEAK ON OPERATOR WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR
DO WE HAVE A MOTION WITH THE
MISTER KARMA'S THE BILL --
ESCRICK SILVA SECOND SAID AND
-- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER BENNETT ECKLEY ASTRID I
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU KNOW THIS BILL WILL
MAKE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST A
MORE EFFECTIVE TOOL TO INCREASE
OUR SUPPLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND AS IT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED MANY TIMES TODAY WE
ALL THE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX
TO GET THROUGH THIS CRISIS
SO APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I'M ALWAYS
SUPPORTING IT TODAY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AND
WITH THAT LET'S TAKE THE ROLE
WICKS HI I'D SAY OCTOBER ALL
RIGHT I DO RELY GABRIEL KALRA
ALL RIGHT I HIGHLY HIGHLY AYE
QUICK SILVA THANKS YOU BY BOARD
THE BILLS -- THANK YOU CAN
WILL MOVE ON NOW TO -- I
DON'T SEEING MR RODRIGUEZ
HERE WILL MOVE ON TO MR
LEVINE -- FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN
FORTY FIVE REQUIRES A COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS TO DELEGATE
SUB REGION OR THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO CONSIDER
EMERGENCY EVACUATION ROUTE
CAPACITY WILDFIRE RISK C.
LEVEL RISE AND OTHER IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
ALLOCATING HOUSING NEED IN
THEIR METHODOLOGY FOR THE RENO
PROCESS CLIMATE DISASTERS IN
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ON OUR STATE HAVE MADE MORE
AND MORE PLACES UNSAFE TO LIVE
WHILE CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
MAKES IT PRONE TO FIRES CLIMATE
CHANGES CAUSED FIRES TO BE
BIGGER THAN EVER BEFORE IN
TWENTY TWENTY AUGUST COMPLEX
FIRE BURNED MORE THAN A MILLION
ACRES CROSSING SEVEN COUNTY
SPANNING AN AREA LARGER THAN
THE STATE OF RHODE ISLAND
BECOMING CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
RECORDED WILDFIRE IN ADDITION
TO FIRES SEVERE DROUGHT IN
PRES RECORD BREAKING HEAT THE
SCIENCE SHOWS US THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE WILL RESULT IN GRADUAL
AND PERMANENT RISE IN SEA
LEVELS POSING A SERIOUS THREAT
TO CALIFORNIANS THE U.
S.
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY ESTIMATES
THAT BY TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
ABOUT SIX FEET OF SEA LEVEL
RISE IN RECURRING ANNUAL
STORMS COULD IMPACT OVER
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THE
INCREASED RISK OF FLOODING
WILL AFFECT BUSINESSES LOCAL
ECONOMIES IN BOTH HOMEOWNERS
AND RENTING HOME PEOPLE RENTING
HOMES WHO ARE LESS ABLE TO
PREPARE THEIR RESIDENCES FOR
FLOOD EVENTS UNFORTUNATELY
AS OUR STATE FACES A CLIMATE
CRISIS IT ALSO FACES A HOUSING
CRISIS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MUST FACTOR THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE DISASTERS ON WHERE TO
BUILD HOUSING WHILE SEEKING TO
EXPAND THE SUPPLY OF HOUSING
UNITS THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT THE IMPENDING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND DISASTERS ON RISK TO
RESIDENTS WHEN PLANNING FOR
ADDITIONAL HOUSING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES OUR STAFF ASPIRIN
ABOUT THANK YOU MR LEVINE
I BELIEVE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION SO WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATE IF YOU GET UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
FOR AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
THE GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY ONE
DAVID WE LIVE IN DAVID WHEATLEY
A LOS ANGELES AND SUPPORT
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK GREAT ANY BRING ABOUT
TO THE COMMITTEE HERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR
SO TO THE OTHER IRATE I HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MIXED FEELINGS
ON THIS BILL I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT IT BUT I AM CONCERNED
THAT THIS DOESN'T GET USED TO
STOP PRODUCTION I KNOW THAT --
CLIMATE ISRAEL AS WE'VE SEEN
WHETHER IT'S FIRE OR FLOOD
OR OTHER ISSUES RELATED SO --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE THOSE
INTO CONSIDERATION I JUST --
I AM HOPING THAT -- THIS WON'T
THEN PUSH THE RESPONSIBILITY
ON OTHER CITIES -- BECAUSE
WE KNOW WHEN WE MENTION RINA
EVERYBODY FALLS APART BUT
SOMETIMES -- WE HAVE SEEN THAT
PUSH FROM ONE AREA TO ANOTHER
-- AND AND THAT THAT IS MY
CONCERN BUT I DEFINITELY TAKE
CLIMATE CHANGE SERIOUSLY CELLS
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T GET INTO THAT
PUSHING AND PULLING WITH RINA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE SUMMER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE BILL MISTER WERE MISSED THE
BILL MR CALLER SECONDS THE BILL
AS WE LIKE TO CLOSE MR LEVINE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER LIVING AND
YOU KNOW WE HONOR THE CLIMATE
CHANGE SHOULD BE A MAJOR
CONSIDERATION ALL OF OUR LONG
TERM PLANNING AND IT'S COMMON
SENSE FOR THIS TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE RENO PROCESS AND SO WITH
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL THE MOTIONS DO PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITHOUT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WICKS HI HI THEY
ARE TO THE ARSENAL CARILLO
GLORIA BY GABRIELLE KALRA
ALL RIGHT I KILEY QUICKSILVER
THANKS SILVA I WORK FOR
TI THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU
HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO ASSEMBLY -- FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AT FOURTEEN TEN
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF CONVERSATIONS I HAD
WITH CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THE
DISCONNECTED BETWEEN HOMEOWNER
RIGHTS AND SOME HOME OWNER
ASSOCIATIONS BEFORE WE GET A
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STUFF FOR WORKING OVER THE IN
ROOM MY OFFICE ON THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL AS WELL AS
PENDING VERIFICATION MEMBERS
THAT ADDRESS NEARLY ALL OF
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS AB
FOURTEEN TEN SIX TO PROTECT
HOME ON RIGHTS BY FIRST
ENSURING THESE IN CHARGE OF
A CHOICE HAVE PROPER ETHICS
AND HARASSMENT TRAINING A
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BREWER
STUDY HAS SHOWN A TREE BOARD
MEMBERS ARE LARGELY UNAWARE
OF FIDUCIARY AND ETHICAL
RESPONSIBILITIES VIOLATION
OF THESE LAWS BECAUSE A TO A
JOINT HOMEOWNERS MONEY WHEN
A BOARD MEMBER STUFF I LIKE
THE LOS HOMEOWNERSHIP NUMBER
THE FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITIES
OF UNIFORM EIGHT CHOI BOARD
MEMBERS OR PERSONNEL OF THE
BILL WOULD PROTECT EIGHT
CHOI BOARD MEMBER STAFF AND
HOMEOWNERS BY ENSURING THOSE
IN CHARGE OF PROPERTY WERE
VERTICAL BOUNDARIES CONNECT
MY BILL ADDRESSES SOMETHING
THAT HAS HAPPENED DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE NATURAL DISASTERS
HOMEOWNERS IN MY DISTRICT
AND BEYOND MY DIFFERENT
HAVE BEEN TRIED FOR MINOR
VIOLATIONS WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN QUARANTINED AND EVACUATED
DURING STATES OF EMERGENCY
THIS BILL IS A COMMONSENSE
MEASURE TO A HOMEOWNER'S RIGHTS
AND PROTECT ALL PARTIES FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE S.
RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE -- ONE
OF OUR ONE PERSON TESTIFYING
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL --
PROPONENT -- RUNS A ROSKI IS
TESTIFYING BY PHONE THE SHOPPER
YOU CAN YOU CONNECT THIS
YES SO GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS IN THE FIRST H.
AWAY IN OCEANSIDE YOU COULD
NOT LIVE THERE ARE FEWER
BLACK HISPANIC CATHOLIC
OR JEWISH TODAY MY UPSCALE
COMMUNITY CALLED ARROWOOD
WILL HOLD STARTED A MILLION
DOLLARS THERE'S A NEW FORM
OF DISCRIMINATION YOU CANNOT
LIVE THERE IF YOU ARE NOT
RETURN OFF TO BUY OR LEASE
THE ENTIRE HOUSE ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO LOOK THEIR MUST
MEET THE HOAS DEFINITION OF
FAMILY WHICH THEY DEFINE AS AN
INTEGRATED ECONOMIC UNIT I'VE
BEEN PRESSURE TO KICK OUT MY
SINGLE MARINES NAVY AND THAT'S
WHO WORK ON CAMP PENDLETON
AND LIVE TOGETHER AS BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN ARMS BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT CONSIDERED A
FAMILY AS A BET IN SUPPORT OF
OUR MEN AND WOMEN WHO DEFEND
OUR FREEDOMS ARE REFUSED
TO GIVE IN TO OUR WHICH AND
REASONABLE DEMANDS MY H.
AWAY IS FINDING ME TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH WITH MY FIND
NOW TOTALING EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND THEY MIGHT LEGAL FEES
ARE JUST UNDER AN ASTOUNDING
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND A FRIEND
OF MINE LIVES IN ANOTHER H.
AWAY -- OCEANSIDE COMMUNITY
AND IT'S HAVING THE SAME FIGHT
SHE'S ABOUT READY TO LOSE THEIR
HEALTH AND DECLARE BANKRUPTCY
FOR SIMPLY HAVING A RENTER IN
OUR HOME THIS IS SO UNFAIR AND
UNAMERICAN I KNOW OF SEVERAL
OTHER HOMEOWNERS WERE BEEN
GIVEN GIVEN INTO THEIR H.
AWAY DEMANDS SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE MONEY
TO FIGHT THEM IT IS SHAMEFUL
THAT MANY SEE ID'S PROHIBIT
HOMEOWNERS FROM SHARING
THEIR HOMES WITH RENTERS THIS
RESTRICTION GOES AGAINST THE
STATED GOAL OF THE STATE TO
CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO GO
TO HELL SIMPLY FOR OFFERING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I FULLY
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN TEN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO FOLKS ONE
-- HERE IN PERSON IS THAT
RIGHT AS A LOUIS BROWN -- YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES PLEASE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS
BROWN TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE
FIRST ONE EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR THE
STAFF -- MORE IMPORTANTLY TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF -- OF FOR
WORKING WITH US IN IN MEETING
WITH US AND TALKING ABOUT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WE HAVE
WITH THE BILL WE DO THINK THE
AMENDMENTS IMPROVE THE BILL AND
START TO MOVE IT IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION ONE OF THINGS WE WANT
TO BRING -- TO THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION AND OTHERS IS A
COUPLE DIFFERENT ISSUES FIRST
WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL BUYS INTO
A HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
THEY'RE PRESENTED WITH THE
CCN OURS THEY'RE SIGNING THE
CCN OURS IS IF THAT THEY'VE
READ THEM AND THAT THEY'VE
UNDERSTOOD THEM WHEN WE MAKE
CHANGES IN THE CIVIL CODE THAT
BASICALLY SAY THAT ACC ARE IS
NO LONGER ENFORCEABLE WE ARE
CHANGING THE RULES OF THE GAME
WE'RE CHANGING THOSE CONTRACT
TERMS THAT EVERYBODY IN THE
ASSOCIATION HAS SIGNED INTO
THERE ARE EXISTING PRACTICES
TO CHANGE CC IN OURS AND
WE'D BE HAPPY TO GET INTO A
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW SOME OF
THOSE PRACTICES CAN BE IMPROVED
BECAUSE MANY TIMES WE CAN SEE
THAT ASSOCIATION IS UNABLE TO
CHANGE THE CCN OURS BECAUSE
OF SOME OF THE EXISTING RULES
THERE BUT I ASKED YOU ON
SOMETHING LIKE A ROOMMATE AND
I UNDERSTAND THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE EARLIER BUT THINK
ABOUT THE IMPACT IT HAS ON THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS THAT ALSO OWN
IN THAT ASSOCIATION THE OTHER
ELEMENT THAT WE WANT TO BRING
UP IS THE COST ANYTIME WE ADD
COSTS TO AN ASSOCIATION THOSE
TRICKLE DOWN TO HOMEOWNERS
IT'S THE HOMEOWNERS THAT PAY
THE MONTHLY ASSESSMENTS AND
ACTUALLY THEN COVER THE BUDGET
FOR THOSE ASSOCIATIONS AND
SO AS WE CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
WE COMPLETELY SUPPORT THAT
WE BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE
THAT CONDOMINIUM ASSOCIATIONS
WILL BE THAT ANSWER OR ONE OF
THE ANSWERS THAT WE FIND IN
CALIFORNIA FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OWNERSHIP
WE NEED TO BE WARY OF THE NEW
WOULD ISSHIN FOR RESTRICTIONS
WE PLACE ON ASSOCIATIONS
THAT ULTIMATELY RAISE THEIR
COSTS AND THEN END UP IN NEW
ASSESSMENT SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR WE THINK THAT THE BILL
STILL NEEDS SOME CLEAN UP
THERE SOME TECH TERMINOLOGY
IN THERE THAT NEEDS TO BE
DEALT WITH WE'LL BE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY BILL MUST ASK
FOR NO VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY --
NOW WE WILL HAVE A BY PHONE
OUR SECOND WITNESS TOM FREELY
-- TOM YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TOM FREELY AND THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGERS WITH OVER
THIRTY YEARS OF HANDS ON C.
ID MANAGEMENT EXPERIENCE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
TEN WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS AGREED TO BY THE
AUTHOR AND APPRECIATE THE WORK
AND INTENTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF THEY
GO A LONG WAY IN IMPROVING THE
BILL CERTAINLY WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IMPOSING
FORMAL TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
ON VOLUNTEER HOMEOWNERS AS
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION ALREADY
STRUGGLE TO FIND PEOPLE
TO SERVE ON THE H.
AWAY BOARDS WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT ANY RESULTING
INCREASE COSTS ON ASSOCIATIONS
WILL RESULT IN INCREASED ON ONE
OR SO ASSESSMENTS ADDITIONALLY
WE BELIEVE MORE CLARIFICATION
IS NEEDED IN THE BILL TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE NO AN
ADVERT AND CONSEQUENCES TO
AN HOAS ABILITY TO REGULATE
SHORT TERM RENTALS CONSISTENT
WITH EXISTING LAW TO ENFORCE
RESTRICTIONS IN SITUATIONS
WHERE HOMEOWNER HAS A LARGER
AND TO ENFORCE VIOLATIONS THAT
ARE NOT DUE TO OR IMPACTED BY
A STATE OF EMERGENCY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE BUT
REMAIN AT THIS TIME OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE WILL NOW GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT OPERATOR AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SUPPORTER POSE
AND AB FOURTEEN TEN -- PLEASE
-- PLEASE DO SO AND AGAIN
ONLY YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IF YOU'RE REPRESENTING ONE
AND -- SUPPORTER OPPOSE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS
ONE ZERO WITH THIS TIME
WE'LL HEAR FROM LINE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI GOOD MORNING COULD OPERATE
TO INTO PORT THANK YOU FIND
ONE SIXTY ONE DAVID WEEKLY IN
OPPOSITION AS IT'S WRITTEN NOW
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND TO PAY MY COLLEAGUES HERE
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THE MISTER SARATOGA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I UNDERSTAND
THE FRUSTRATIONS WITH HOAS
-- AND THAT'S WHY I CHOOSE
NOT TO LIVE IN AN H.
AWAY -- GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY
BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE DO LIVE IN THEM AND
THEY LIVE IN THEM BECAUSE --
THEY WANT A MORE RESTRICTIVE
-- BODY THAT GOVERNS THEIR
COMMUNITY AND IT MAINTAINS
A CERTAIN STANDARD FOR THAT
COMMUNITY I REALLY HESITATE TO
TRY TO IMPOSE LESS RESTRICTIONS
ON THOSE EIGHT ARE MORE
RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT HOAS CAN
ACCOMPLISH THE YEARLY STRUGGLE
FOR THEM TO GET SOMEBODY
ANYBODY TO SERVE ON THE BOARD
IS ONE MOST THANKLESS JOBS
EVER -- IS IS HOW IT'S ALREADY
DIFFICULT -- AND TELLING THEM
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GO HAVE
TO TAKE THAT YOU KNOW THAT THEN
THE COURSES THAT WE ALL HAVE
TO TAKE TO BE ABLE TO BE AN
IN PUBLIC SERVICE -- IT WILL
CAN PRETTY MUCH IN THAT -- AND
YOU'LL WIND UP WITH AN H.
AWAY GOVERNED BY THE COMMUNITY
DIRECTOR I GUESS -- SO
THAT KIND OF ELIMINATES
THE THE MECHANISM THAT THEY
HAVE -- TO ADDRESS THEIR
GRIPES WITHIN THE H.
AWAY THERE'S A PROCESS IT
EXISTS PEOPLE HAVE A CHOICE YOU
CAN YOU TO LIVE IN A COMMUNITY
LIKE THAT OR NOT AND -- AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY UP TO THEM
TO DECIDE THAT IF THEY DON'T
WANT TO THEN THEY SHOULDN'T --
BUT THEY SHOULDN'T MOVE INTO
IT AND THEN ONE HAS TO FIX
IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING THE
WAY THEY WANT AND I SYMPATHIZE
WITH THIS POOR GENTLEMAN THAT
CALLED AND NOW WITH HIS ISSUES
THERE -- BUT -- YEAH HARD FOR
ME TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE OF
THAT I JUST DON'T LIKE TO DELVE
INTO HOAS AND -- AND YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THERE FOR A REASON
WHEN PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE
JIM FOR A REASON AND -- I
DON'T THINK IT'S OUR PLACE
TO -- TO GO IN AND TELL THEM
THEY CAN'T DO THAT ANYMORE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES ON
THE DAIS IS THERE A MOTION
MR COLOR MOVES OF THE
MISCREANTS SECONDS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES OUR FIRST
ONE WANT TO CONTINUE TO TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION AND ADDRESS OUR
NEEDS AS WE ALREADY HAVE BEEN
I THINK -- THERE IS A NEED TO
MAKE SOME MODIFICATIONS AND
CHANGES OFFICER WE SEE SOME
THERE ARE SOME GOOD CHOICES
ABOUT A CHOICE BUT I THINK
WE GET THE MORE -- UP TO PAR
AND THINGS WHEN IT COMES TO
HARASSMENT AND AT THE TRAINING
I THINK IT'S A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYBODY NOBODY LIKES CHANGE
BUT IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE DO AT
THIS BUILDING TO ADVOCATE FOR
FOLKS IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
AND DIFFERENT AREAS US
WITHOUT RESPECT S.
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOUR MR
RODRIGUEZ -- YOU KNOW COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS ARE
GROWING SEGMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING SUPPLY THIS BILL
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF PROVISIONS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
HOMEOWNERS GET FAIR TREATMENT
BY THEIR HOAS I UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE STILL CONCERNS FROM
SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
THE BILL WILL BE SUPPORTING
TODAY THE BILL TODAY BUT --
WITH THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
MOMENTS THAT WILL BE TAKEN
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
HAVE MORE CONVERSATIONS TO
HOPEFULLY FIND SOME MORE COMMON
GROUND AS YOU GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AT THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY --
SUPPORTING I'M SUPPORTING AGAIN
WITH AMENDMENTS -- THAT WILL
BE A -- TAKEN UP IN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WITH THAT PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE WICKS HI HI WE ARE
DON'T SEE ARE NO CARILLO GLORIA
AYE GABRIEL CHOLERA CHOLERA I
KILEY HIGHLY NO -- QUICK SILVA
QUICKSILVER I WORK FOR TI
WE HAVE FOUR --
IT'S IT'S ON CALL
CORRECT AND I BELIEVE MISTER
WARD IS PRESENTING OUR LAST
BILL HERE ON BEHALF OF MR
SANTIAGO AB FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- THAT
I AM HAPPY TO BE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE SOME MEMBER SANTIAGO
TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
ONE ON STARK DISPLAY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL BE TAKEN UP BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
AND AS AMENDED THIS BILL
WOULD REINSTATE THE DENSITY
BONUS PROGRAM FOR COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES WITH A NEW SENSE OF
DATE OF JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS EXTENSION
WILL CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
UNDER LOCAL GOVERNMENT APPROVAL
BY GIVING COMMERCIAL DEVELOPERS
BONUSES AND INCENTIVES AS
LONG AS WE PARTNER WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
TO CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BY REINSTATING AB NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR PROVISIONS THIS
BILL WILL HELP MEET THE STATE'S
NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DESIRE
FOR INCREASED REVENUES -- WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS I BELIEVE YOUR
CALL IN AS HUNT EVEN WITH THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
THANK YOU MR WARDEN I BELIEVE
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS -- DEBRA
SCHNEIDER -- WHO SHOULD BE
ON THE PHONE AND EVER IF YOU
THAT YOU WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
HI ACTUALLY MILD JOHNSON FROM
THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
SORRY ABOUT THAT WE ARE A BIT
NO WORRIES WE'RE A BAY AREA
NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES FOR
BUILDING MORE HOMES RESIDENTS
OF ALL INCOME LEVELS HERE TO
SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL COOKS THAT EXTEND AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE CALIFORNIANS
CURRENTLY DEALING WITH A
SEVERE SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BY TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STRUGGLE WITH HOUSING
INSECURITY ARE CONSTANTLY AT
RISK OF BECOMING DISPLACED
OR HOMELESS INCENTIVES THAT
ENCOURAGE THE CREATION OF MORE
HOMES LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ARE ESSENTIAL I URGE
VOTERS TO EXTEND THE BILL AND
SUPPORT THE PRODUCTION OF MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I BELIEVE
WE HAVE NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND NO -- WITNESSES
-- IN OPPOSITION AT WITH
THAT OPERATOR LET'S GO TO THE
PHONES IF WE OF FOLKS IN THE
PUBLIC WHEN A REGISTERED THEIR
OPPOSITION SUPPORT PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU DO SO BY JUST SITTING
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF IT'S
RELEVANT AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THANK CHAIR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE CITY
TO IS NOT A REQUIREMENT BY
OTHER PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF -- IN PART THANK YOU ONE
ONE SIXTY ONE DAVID WHEATLEY
IN LOS ANGELES IN OPPOSITION
AND A FINAL CALL FROM ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
CODE ONLINE SEVENTY FIVE
YES I AM NOT RIGHT THE PORT
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE COULD
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU OPERATOR WE WILL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE COMMITTEE I JUST ONE
QUESTION -- MAYBE YOU CAN
ANSWER MAYBE NOT HOW OFTEN
IS THIS USED THANK YOU AND
AS THE SAME QUESTION AND ONE
IS NOT BEEN USED TO DATE --
THE CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
AUTHOR AND OTHER -- PROPONENTS
HAVE SUGGESTED THAT THERE ARE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET FOR A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE TRYING
TO MAKE IT WORK INTERESTING
YEAH THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE
IT WORK PART THAT'S THE THAT'S
WHAT WE GOT TO WORK ON THANKS
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS DO WE HAVE
A MOTION THE MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO SECOND BY MISTER KALRA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE QUICKLY
ESPERANDO THANK YOU MISTER WERE
THIS IS ANOTHER CREATIVE IDEA
TO HELP FACILITATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LET'S HOPE IT'S USED
MORE WIDELY UTILIZED IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS -- THE MOTIONS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN LOOK ABOVE IT HAS MY
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD BE TAKEN UP IN LOCAL GOV
WITH THAT PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE
WEEKS HI HI THEY ARE TWO OF A
CARILLO HI GABRIEL HI APRIL
HI KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE QUICKSILVER THANKS SILVA I
WARD FORTY FIVE THE BILLS OUT
WE WILL NOW GO BACK
FIVE ONE YEAH
ONE NOTE NOW GO BACK TO
FILE ITEM ONE FOR THE VOTE
FOR TO PUT THESE ARE A BILL
BILL AB SIX SEVEN TO THE
VOTE IS FORTY TWO GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA HI
SO IT'S THE BILL'S ON FIFTH
ITEM NUMBER TWO -- BILL AB
SIX EIGHT TO -- BY EVERY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLUE WICKS OUR
WEEKS I SAY OCTOBER C.
R.
NO CORREO HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA KILEY
QUICKSILVER KIRK SILVA I
WORK FOR TI THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE IN MY -- NUMBER THREE
AB EIGHT FIVE FORCE THE BILL
HAS A SIXTY TWO AT THE MOMENT
THAT WE'RE NEEDS TO ADD OR
-- I THINK -- -- ITEM NUMBER
FOUR NINE ONE SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS GABRIEL GABRIEL
I KALRA KALRA AYE WARD WARD I
THAT BILLS ARE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWELVE
OH SIX -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL GABRIEL I BOARD WORK
I AND THAT THAT BILLS OUT
ITEM NUMBER SIX THE AB FOURTEEN
TEN -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
THAT IS AT FIVE THAT BILLS
ARE -- I AM NUMBER SEVEN
AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL APRIL
I HIGHLY LET FOR A SIX ONE
DOUBLES OUT AND NOW WE ARE
AT THE CLOSE OF BUSINESS SAVE
BE FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE NUMBER
EIGHT WELL OUR THANK YOU FOR
MAKING MY FIRST A COMMITTEE
MEETING A GOOD ONE THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANKS